this is jocko podcast number 248 with
echo charles
and me jocko willink good evening echo
good evening
as the summer of 1970 evolved
the dead deadly secret war in laos raged
into its
sixth year the communist nva and its
secret advisors from russia
china and cuba continued supplying
growing numbers of light and heavy
weapons
state-of-the-art anti-aircraft artillery
missiles
and vehicles the communist campaign
against
sag reconnaissance teams resulted in the
green berets
exceeding a 100 percent casualty rate
meaning of the special forces soldiers
who went across the fence
into laos and cambodia all were either
killed in action
wounded more than once in combat with
enemy forces
or they simply disappeared
as of july 4th 2017 there are 50 green
berets
listed as missing in action in laos
alone from the secret war
along with 105 aviators who died
supporting
sog missions
sog hatchet force operations of platoon
or company-sized missions
didn't fare much better in an effort to
bring
a temporary halt to shipping supplies
flowing down the ho chi minh trail
three separate hatchet force slam
operations
were conducted in laos west of south
vietnam
between march 1969 and february 1970.
the area of operations was code named
prairie fire again
due to the severe political constraints
placed on sog operations the prairie
fire
area of operations extended west of
south vietnam
about 30 miles no sag teams went beyond
that area of operations the three slam
operations were titled night cap spin
down
and half back each of those operations
had a hatchet force company helicoptered
to a hilltop on the main
segment of the ho chi minh trail the
trips would dig
in set up ambushes and target nva
trucking
after the lead trucks were hit there
would be a traffic
backup along the jungle trail
oftentimes large portions of the ho chi
minh trail were not visible from air due
to clever camouflage efforts by the nva
and their constrict conscripted forced
labor
of local indigenous tribe people
thus when the first trucks were hit
hatchet force
radio operators would call in tactical
air support to destroy as many
enemy trucks and soldiers as possible
eventually after a few days the nva
masked hundreds of soldiers to hammer
the hatchet force positions
inflicting serious casualties upon the
entrenched troops
forcing their extraction from the area
of operations
during the last mission operation
halfback
an h-34 south vietnamese air force
helicopter
from the 219th special operations
squadron
was shot down killing all passengers
aboard the old
war bird including special forces medic
sergeant first class bill doyle
those operations were viewed as
successes due to the amount of
enemy trucks supplies and troops
destroyed during the intense battles
the three slam operations were launched
from the top secret sog base
in command kantoom control central
the last slam operation was run by bee
company in hatchet force command
by the end of august 1970 greenbrae
captain gene mccarley became the
commander of b
company mccarly was a sog veteran
having run missions during the last few
months of 1967
and into 1968 when he was assigned
to rt florida out of contume in 1968.
rt florida ran a series of successful
missions including a trail watch
wiretaps of nva phone lines and planning
air force sensors
alongside a trail at the end of august
mccarly heard through the grapevine that
a major
hatchet force operation was coming
through the chain of command
and he volunteered b company for it
assuming it might be another slam
operation mccarley researched
and the after actions reports from the
previous missions
he talked to team members in camp about
those operations
their successes their shortcomings
in the first days of september 1970
the operations order came down and was
assigned to be
company under the command of mccarly
it was dubbed operation tailwind
and much to mccarly's surprise operation
tailwind was targeted
for the deepest insertion into laos ever
by a sog team
25 to 30 miles beyond the normal
area of operations
the operation was dead was designed to
take pressure off a cia operation
further southwest bordering cambodia
because of the unique nature of this
mission mccarley drew upon his years of
operational
experience in laos for a daring new
tactic
instead of remaining in a static
position like the earlier slam missions
once the full element
b company 15 green berets and 120
highly trained mountain guard tribesmen
were on the ground in the deepest
penetration of enemy territory during
the secret war
he would move day and night supported by
air assets from the air force army and
marine corps
it would be an epic mission
in hindsight 47 years later
although no one said so at the time most
agreed
it was a suicide mission
and that right there is from the
prologue
of a book called sog chronicles
volume 1 written by
john striker meyer otherwise known by
his nickname
and code name and call sign
tilt and it is once again
an honor to have tilt here with us
as he has been here before for podcasts
180
181 182 186
247 and now 248 and if you haven't
listened to those
yet go listen to them to understand
what sag was and what heroes these men
were
including this man my hero
john striker meyer tilt thanks for
coming back on
good evening sir good evening welcome
thanks for coming back it's my honor so
um this is just a story that you know
you and i had talked about
some of the different stories that we've
covered and and you know you've kind of
i guess you kind of somehow ended up
being a little bit of the the sog
historian
capturing a bunch of these stories from
different operations even when you
weren't there but interviewing guys
talking to them gathering all this
information
and then captured and put into these
books but it has the
i mean since you were in song and you
operated in these areas of
of operations that these guys were in
the way you're able to tell the story is
is is powerful well thank you um
but this book here is the first one that
doesn't have my stories
and that's what i like because that's
what my goal is going to be for
um sod chronicles is my little humble
company
and we're going to write these stories
until we die because there's so many
that have never been told
and this mission operation tale when it
was a classic
i'd heard little tidbits about it over
the years
but until and we'll get into the details
later how in 98
there are some facts that came out
twisted on that due to the communist
news network but
factually this is just an amazing
mission and there's so many levels
and it was a classic example of a saga
operation with
men on the ground doing the mission got
it accomplished
and they worked with army
air force and marine corps air assets
everything from fast movers to gun ships
and gene mccarley was just an
outstanding soldier
a soldier soldier and he you know he
started as enlisted
became an officer so he never lost that
grounding
but it's just one hell of a commander
and here he just that was his concept
and they ran with it and as we get into
the story just
amazing stuff yeah the the air
superiority that
we had was really powerful but you have
to remember
that it wasn't total air superiority it
wasn't like
look we have air superiority in iraq and
afghanistan
we very rarely will lose an aircraft and
usually it's because there's some kind
of an accident or a crash or something
like that
but even though we it's pretty easy to
say oh yeah we had full air superiority
in in vietnam
we had a certain level of confidence but
at the same time
we didn't have totally or superiority
because there was still
there were still aircraft getting shot
down by either migs or getting shot down
by surface-to-air missiles
yeah because you had two separate air
wars
you had the air war over north vietnam
that's the air force in the navy just
pounding away
losing hundreds of men and it had the
whole pow
where many were returned i forget the
exact number
and they came back in february of 73
through april 73. they came back
so that is more of a traditional yeah
those migs that were trained by the
russians
etc and some even said the russians flew
i don't know
we were more concerned with down south
and the prairie fire ao
in cambodia over time as the war
progressed particularly
after lyndon johnson had the bombing
hall in 78
man the anti-aircraft stuff the 12.7 is
the 23 millimeter 37 mic mic
and heavier stuff and one of the stories
later here
is one of our medics he remembers flying
out
and we'll have some cover that's a
little bit of his story later but on a
way out there's
akkack in the air just like world war ii
when you see uh you know 12 o'clock high
and all those
you see all the ackak that shot down all
of our airplanes in world war ii there
it was
courtesy of the russians and they were
shooting at our helicopters
yeah and so doc padgett was like oh my
god this is like watching a world war
ii movie but it's right here and so
that's our war and yes it's like
movie except i think i might get killed
yeah
and in world war ii they didn't have any
helicopters that we know about
and so that is the aspect where like in
your introduction we talked about the
mias to this day
missing in action the americans that
were shot down supporting saag
that's everything from fast movers down
to the smallest helicopters the loose
and of course your vietnamese air force
like
with the story we talked about on
tuesday with lynn black
on the visual reconnaissance it's just a
little dinky observation aircraft
the co-pilot gets his head blown off
literally and his head in the helmet
lands in the lens lap
so those are the casualties that that
went into our war
that's our side of the air war so we
dominated the air but that air was full
of
anti-aircraft weaponry deadly yeah
absolutely
well i guess we should get into this
this story because um this this tailwind
is
is just kind of crazy just another day
another day all right so here we go
going to the book sog chronicles
volume one and for everyone that's
hopeful out there there's gonna be
volume two three four
five the lord willing
i know there's there's more stories when
you got time to write i mean it's gonna
there's so many stories
every one of these operations is its own
book oh yeah
you know every time i read one of your
books and i read
one operation i think there's a whole
story
a whole book a three or four hundred
page book about every single operation
if you start going into the granular
detail in the back story
it's it's crazy so get to work
tilt keep writing yes sir
all right so here we go routinely under
protocols established in
early sag secret war most laotian
sog operators were limited to 20
kilometers west of vietnam's borders
operation tailwind was booked to go
approximately 40
kilometers further west beyond that
limitation
to go that deep into laos required
formal approval from the laotian
ambassador and from the u.s commander of
all forces in vietnam
general creighton at abrams mccarly
the b company commanding officer at the
top secret sag com
compound in con tomb am i saying that
right calm tomb cartoon
commanding control central got the word
from s3 on september 4th 1970
and he says i remember getting called by
s3 and they told me that we had a
special mission
a mission that was deep into laos a
mission deeper into laos than
ever before and a mission bigger than
any before
in the prairie fire ao
said mccarley they told me to go heavy
on
ammo and demo i knew that such a mission
would take special clearance up to the
ambassador
who is no friend of sog and from abrams
that's general abrams who is no big
fan of special forces in short order he
learned
that all of the approvals had been
received and signed off so this is a
massive mission bigger than any
mission deeper into laos than ever
before
and that means you got to get you got to
get approval from the ambassador
and generally if you don't know this
ambassadors usually aren't fond of
military actions inside their
inside their arenas right that they have
that one ambassador just
made life so difficult for sog from
every day that we're
open there yeah i mean ambassadors if
you think about it just from a
philosophical
level you know they want to solve things
through diplomacy
and and so generally they have a little
bit of a
of a friction with the military elements
generally not always
and then you have abrams who's not a fan
of special forces
which i believe we've done a good job of
moving this in a better direction
but there certainly has been tension
from time to time between conventional
forces and special forces
and special operations guys uh generally
because
special operations guys well they don't
follow the same rules all the time that
the conventional guys follow and they
might have a little bit of an attitude
and that can rub them the wrong way and
maybe and a little bit
so you know you got a guy like general
abrams that doesn't like special forces
except when he needs him except when he
needs him well there you go and he
needed him here
so uh continuing on
later that day s3 provided more specific
details go
heavy create havoc for the nva and keep
them busy as long as possible
mccarly a former team leader of sog
recon team florida where he ran seven
seven successful missions
transferred to the hatchet force where
green berets ran platoon and
company-sized operations
across the fence in laos and cambodia so
just so everyone gets a grip on this
these hatchet forces now you have
instead of having
12 guys on the ground or six or six guys
on the ground like you would with one of
your
recon teams yeah now you're talking
about
a group of special forces guys maybe 10
12
15 special forces american special
forces guys
and then 120 or 150
indige forces locals yeah
and so in this case they're mountain
yards
and that means you can conduct these
bigger operations and that's really
the the fundamental mission of special
forces of the green berets is to work
with in-ditch forces train up these
guerrilla forces so that they can become
a strong fighting unit
the seals have a different primary
mission the seal's primary mission
was always generally considered to be
special uh direct action and special
reconnaissance
find the enemy kill yep that's that's
that's the seals
and the the special forces was more hey
find the enemy and then train some of
the local populists to go kill them
that's the goal
and it's more of a long-term solution
you know you'll hear the green beret say
it's
teach him how to fish instead of just
giving him a fish seal teams we just
kill the fish
we just kill the fish generally now we
both cross over
and we both do each one you know we do
their operations when i was in ramadi we
that's what we did we trained a bunch of
the indige forces a bunch of iraqi
soldiers and you know of course there
were special forces units that were
doing all kinds of direct action
missiles missions there as well so we do
cross over
but if you look at the kind of bread and
butter this is just
bread and butter green beret operation a
massive in-ditch force
going into to to do to harass the enemy
oh yeah this is what it this is what it
is take the pressure off of the cia
which was getting his ass kicked explain
that background a little bit about this
what's going on with the cia there well
at that time uh premier
synoc had been asked it and this is 1970
i forget the exact month but like
may or june right around there so he
leaves country there's a political
vacuum
and so the columnists want to head south
in mass
to get as many troops in cambodia just
to take it
because the nva knew there was a khmer
rouge element
that was on the sideline and growing in
strength
in cambodia so
the cgia put this operation together
which was further deeper
into the layoffs near the border and
the nva came at them hard now they had 5
000 cia troops
and they were getting their ass kicked
and they said help
so they came up with this concept have
the team go in
and then gene mccarley put his little
unique spin to it
after talking because by 1970 uh
particularly out of contume those
hatchet forces were good
they really knew how to work with the
air assets and uh
which includes spectre at night and so
gene knew all about that stuff
and uh so he put that idea together
and it worked in terms of drawing away
nva
from the cia which in the end mission
accomplished
not only did they draw them away the cia
could hold
but they also had some major enemy
caches in the command post
and that's why my favorite picture on
the front page there's a picture of our
guys
from cartoon standing with a picture ho
chi minh
which was taken from one of the tables
in the
command center there that was the nva
command center
when i was going through what they call
seal it was called seal tactical
training before that was called seal
basic indock and then it became seal
qualification training it's like what
you do when you get done with the basic
training
we did a raid on a target and
this is up in fort lewis washington and
so we do a raid on a target
and they've they're flying a flag
on this little compound right and
they're flying this flag and sure enough
the
the the officer in charge of our class
which was now the the platoon commander
of our platoon going to do this hit
he sees that flag walks over to it
undoes the figure eight
starts pulling it down and sure enough
the instructors have booby-trapped that
thing and it blows up
you're a casualty so when i see that
picture on the cover
i always think man i was always scared
to touch anything that look
good absolutely oh yeah if the first day
if it looks good maybe it's too good
yeah uh but you know those um
a lot of guys a lot of guy i know a lot
of guys from
from the war in iraq a lot of guys went
home with
with paintings of saddam hussein because
those things were pretty easy to find
they were everywhere
yes indeed yeah all right going back to
the book
with the hatchet force or the hatchet
force we were used to going across the
fence and getting our ass kicked and
then getting saved by tack air
on operation half back in laos earlier
in the year we lost two
south vietnamese air force h-34s which
included
sf medic bill boyle who died in one of
those choppers
we got hit hard because we were dug in
and the nva pounded our position
with operation tailwood tailwind once on
the ground
we were going to keep moving day and
night to keep the nva off balance and
keep them
from massing a large force against our
position
it's it's fundamental it's what we're
talking about is maneuver warfare right
instead of saying hey we'll do attrition
warfare we'll sit on this this
mountaintop and you attack us
hey we're going to move around and you
know won't know where where we are
but that's tricky too moving 150 guys
around in the j
in the jungle indeed in the j as they
say
although no one said so at the time at
least not outright the mission that
mccarley and the ccc
hatchet force were gearing up for to
execute could be called a suicide
mission
as mccarley briefed the b company
platoon leaders
squad leaders medic gary mike rose
and company first sergeant morris adair
in the
ccc compound operation orders
were going out to critical support
elements that would play crucial roles
in operation tailwind first there was a
long distance to the target in laos
because it was so far away neither the
older piston driven h-34 sikorsky
helicopters the south vietnamese armies
or south south vietnamese air force 219
special operations squadron
nor regular army huey slicks could be
used to insert
and extract the 136-man attachment so
you got just a straight-up fuel
limitation absolutely these aircraft
they're not going to be able to fly that
deep into laos
so what does that mean back to the book
thus
sag brass turned to the marine corps
aviation wing that flew the largest
troop carriers in vietnam
the powerful ch-53d
sikorsky twin-engine helicopters in
hmh 463 based at the coors
marble mountain air facility using the
bigger stronger heavier
lift helicopters made sense because
three sea stallions
with the with the design capacity to
hold 55 troops
could take the entire hatchet force of
136 men
all their equipment and extra supplies
such as explosives and
ammunition and insert them into the
target area
so there you go the uh the uh ch-53
helicopter is a massive freaking
helicopter
oh yeah it holds 50-something troops
with all their gear with their gear and
all the rounds for their weapons yeah
that's a that's an
awesome aircraft and those were the only
two engines in them
this v40 came out with a three engine
model like you used
oh see i got that i got it easy
um in previous years marine corps
aviators
from hmh 463 had performed fearlessly in
key sog operations across the fence
and marine brass knew that flying combat
troops and supplies into laos always
resulted in the helicopters
getting hit by enemy fire
in the first day said mccarley it was
funny the marine brass were a little
reluctant to go that deep into laos
because they knew
the sog missions presented extra
challenges and dangers
to marine air crews but once they heard
about the unique aspects of operations
t operation tailwind they wanted in
marine sergeant larry grow am i saying
that right grow
was a door gunner instructional mechanic
structural mechanic in hmh
463 when the operations order came into
the command shed in da nang
the most dangerous and he says the most
dangerous
and most interesting missions we flew
were mission
72 and that was sog support
we called it going over the fence for me
personally
this is why i joined the marine corps to
run special missions against the enemy
i was looking for adventure and wanted
to be where the action was
the marine aviators were told to prepare
for a mission
72 insertion deep into laos
grow replaced the 50 caliber machine gun
with the m60 because it
gave him more maneuverability and if we
got shot down
he says and and quote if we got shot
down i could carry it
and take the fight to the enemy the 50
was too heavy to carry
is that a great marine or what yeah yeah
so just so everyone understands what
we're talking about a 50 caliber machine
gun is a big gun
and it's you can't shoot it you can't
you cannot do it you can't you can't
carry that thing and shoot it from
your shoulder or from your hip it's it's
meant to be mounted on a vehicle or
mounted in an aircraft
but an m60 you can shoot by yourself
you can carry it and you can you can
fire it from the hip or from the
shoulder
and so this marines thinking well we're
going out these freaking sog guys
probably a pretty decent chance we're
gonna get shot down i'll go ahead and
switch it out that way if we get shot
down i'll be able to
you know uh unhook that thing and go and
fight
larry's a thinker marine boy he's
something he's one of my all-time heroes
from this mission dang yeah um
not far away from hmh 463 at marble
mountain air facility
marine aviators from hml 367
scarface got the op order for operation
tailwind
in a more dramatic fashion according to
cobra gunship pilot
joe driscoll who was a first lieutenant
at the time and he says the duty driver
came by our room at two or three o'clock
in the morning and told us to pack our
gear as we'd be gone for five to ten
days on an operation to be ready at five
am
my first thought was maybe we're finally
going into north vietnam
driscoll and fellow pilots flew the
early model ah-1g
cobra gun ships with one man sitting in
front seat
and a pilot sitting behind him a
relative of the more familiar huey
helicopter the cobra gunship
had a more narrow profile designed
strictly as a weapons platform
driscoll cope driscoll's cobra had two
19 shot
2.75 rocket launchers two seven shot
rocket pods one seven six two
mini gun that fired six thousand rounds
a minute and a grenade launcher that
fired
forty millimeter high explosive rounds
that's why they call it a gunship that's
firepower
when the early versions of those cobras
were fully armed and loaded with
aviation fuel the helicopter skids would
drag on the runway for a short distance
until the pilots gained enough lift to
get the bird airborne
however once once in the air they
brought the fight to the enemy with
precise gun runs and
rocket runs scarface and several other
marine helicopter units
had been involved in the secret war in
vietnam for several years usually
supporting recon teams and hatchet
forces
from fob-1 at fubai and fob-3 at caisson
or
fob-4 at da nang
in the northern and you're just this
this section of the book is laying out
and i'm skipping through it like
i always have to skip through some stuff
get it get the book so you can get the
rest of the details
but you know you mentioned that this was
a massive joint operation through all
these different forces and in this
section you're laying out the various
air
platforms that are going to be brought
to bear to execute this mission
you go on here in the northern side of
da nang at the joint military civilian
airfield
air force spad pilots who flew the
single win
single wing a1 skyraiders received
their initial op order for operation
tailwind
so the a1 the a1 skyraider is this
old-school
world war ii era right invented and put
together at the end of world war ii
used throughout korean war and then
the air force brass put them all away
and then
jack singh lob and other commanders said
we want those aircraft back in service
they had this big battle behind the
scenes to get the skyraider
because they were just phenomenal
support for sog
um the nickname spad
world war one i looked it up it's an old
world war one
airplane and this thing was such an
ancient beast yes that they
they called it the spad the world war
one airplane
oh awesome looking bird uh going on here
the single the single engine warplane
was loved by american ground pounders
this is kind of like the a10
oh yeah you know the a10 is the same
thing people try and get rid of it and
all the ground pounders say we love that
thing
absolutely we love that the only thing
the a10 was missing was napalm
yeah that would have been nice oh yeah
crispy critter time
the single-engine warplane was loved by
american ground pounders and feared by
communist troops because of the havoc
and death they rained down
on enemy troops additionally through the
unique design
by ed heinemann at douglas aircraft
company during world war ii the
skyraider could stay on station over a
target
longer than any aircraft and it brought
bombs
cluster bombs 2.75 rockets 20 millimeter
cannons
and two mini guns to the battlefield
once again that's a lot of firepower
plus bombs and napalm
over the years several sog recon and
hatchet forest green berets were called
getting
showered with shell casings from the a1
skyraiders as they flew danger close to
the teams
they were supporting some later reported
receiving burns on the back of their
necks from hot shell casings that fell
from the warbird
and landed on the soldier's necks
burning their skin once they lodged
in the collar however no one ever
complained about those burns
burns that were often life savings
life-saving
lieutenant colonel melvin swanson was
the group commander
when operation tailwind op order landed
on his desk
and here's what he had to say to tell
the truth we didn't do anything special
when the op order came down
i had no idea where we were going we
operated like any other sog mission that
we'd supported over the years
we had two a1's armed and cocked ready
to go for sog missions
and search and rescue missions we prided
ourselves on saving sog
teams sog missions were our primary
assignment
with sar as the other priority when they
called
we answered always
back at ccc and khan tomb mccarly
restated the mission to his platoon
leaders and squad leaders
go heavy on ammo grenades and c4 plastic
explosives
and light on food and water
and he says i had every team member
including our in-ditch troops carry at
least one pound of c4
because we were going to blow up any
enemy caches and structures we found
and c4 was always good for clearing lz's
green beret medic gary mike rose went
through his mental checklist
preparing to carry enough medical
supplies and bandages for a
company-sized operation
he would make sure that each green beret
team member carried at least one
morphine syrette
in a specific pocket he also made sure
that he packed that each packed several
sizes of bandages and at least one iv he
packed about 15
syrettes of morphine five sorrets of
atropine
he he always carried five for insert and
snake bites even in camp
as well as extra bandages medical tape
rubber tubing
and several nato surgical kits rose
worked with his modern yard
koch is that right [ __ ] koch cut
who he described as a loyal brave
soldier
and medic who carried a similar amount
of medical supplies that i carried
and like many young soldiers rose never
thought for a minute
that he would be wounded during combat
thus the stage was set for launching
operation tailwind on september 11
1970 after several weather delays and
rocket attacks
to the launch site north of ccc
it would be a mission where the 16 green
berets
would receive a total of 33 purple
hearts
for wounds received during the heavy
combat that was about to unfold
in laos
oh yeah and the the fun thing here is we
this is the first time
we were able to interview all the
aviators like mel swanson won a
character
and then joe driscoll and his cohorts
from
um scarface and then met larry
and a couple other it's on the pilots
over time yeah and we'll get to it
because you mentioned in the book and
you talk through that but
a lot of times you'd never even see
these guys never i mean they're
stationed in a different place they're
up in the air you're on the ground and
you never you just never you never meet
them never and look i mean you you've
you've heard all the stories mine lynn
black the frenchman
elton barr as well we all have
skyraiders stories that love and saved
our bacon
i couldn't tell you one pilot's name not
until we had
uh until we had this story and that was
even there 40 45 years later
dang yes
so here we go let's get to it after
seven days of weather delays false
starts and enemy rocket attacks
um at the top secret military assistance
command
base in vietnam
eugene mccarley that's the the guy in
charge eugene mccarley gave the order to
move out
15 berets 15 green berets and 120
modern yards mercenaries
on the morning of september 11th four of
the powerful
marine corps ch-53d sikorsky twin
engine helicopters in hmh 463
based at the marine corps marble
mountain air facility landed outside the
ccc compound and loaded up the 136
man unit sog brass had turned to the
marine corps aviation wing
that flew the largest troop carriers to
reach into laos
25 kilometers beyond the normal sog
area of operations escorted by six
marine corps cobras the helicopters
headed north to refuel at dak
ii before heading into the target area
after refueling
they flew north parallel to the border
for a while before taking a left turn
heading due west into the target area
could the cobras make it all the way in
yes
that's pretty impressive yeah they had
extra fuel capacity
got it and here's uh speaking of the
pilots that you got to interview
it was a hot zone from the moment we
arrived scarface cobra pilot joe
driscoll said
we took several hits on the first gun
run
during the insertion of the team
scarface pilot sid baker and i were
surprised by the volume of fire
in fact we took hits in our rocket pods
we had bullet holes in our tail boom
and they shot out our radio when the
cobras made their final gun run
we followed our sop which was to stay in
formation and keep an eye out for enemy
soldiers firing at us
end quote because they had no radio
contact driscoll
and baker simply flew through flew
through the pattern to cover the ship in
front of them
without firing quote the enemy didn't
know
we had no radios i'll tell you one thing
that was a hot target driscoll said we
were moving targets
the ch-53s were static targets but they
went in
dropped off the troops and got out of
there post haste
man yeah on insert okay see ordinarily
we're done
we get shot at going in unless you're
lynn black and his 1-0
but ordinarily you're done you just turn
around and go home
we're compromised the idea is to get
inserted do a mission without being
compromised
there by our old standards were
compromised operation tailwind we're
going in
come hell or high water it gets better
oh yeah
continuing the ch-53s were big targets
mccarley said all of the ch-53s were hit
by enemy ground fire while end route to
the target
i'd never received so much ground fire
while flying to a target he said
it sounded like a bb gun shooting a tin
can but it wasn't bb's that the troops
heard it was enemy rounds
by the time that b company exited the
helicopters four mont yards had been
wounded from enemy gunfire
one died while flying back to base with
his three
wounded comrade in arms green beret
medic sergeant michael rose added it was
strange
exiting the chopper stepping over
wounded in action to get to the ground
yeah so they haven't even started the
mission yet they got one killed and
three wounded yes we haven't started the
mission yet but we got
we got three wounded and one killed
continuing under ordinary sog mission
sops any recon team or hatchet force
that received enemy ground fire and men
wounded in action
prior to getting to the ground would
cancel the mission
this was no ordinary mission company b
moved off the helicopters
and was on the ground in laos shortly
after noon
time one fundamental truism of the
vietnam war
as well as the eight years secret
surfaced
the communist forces fought when they
wanted to fight
thus when mccarley and the main
remaining 131 members of b
company settled into the woodline they
found complete and utter silence
he said it was so strange the aircraft
pulled back we were on the ground
and there were no enemy soldiers no
noise no birds nothing
so once again you get that that weird
quietness oh yeah
what do you think make the make the nva
think we're going to shoot when they're
inserting but
once they land we're not going to do
anything what are they thinking what's
the enemy thinking at that point
who knows their tactics always varied
and i think a little bit was just a
complete element of surprise
they saw the birds and so the people
shooting it would be anti-aircraft crews
along the way
and probably some ground troops for
their aks i don't know i wasn't there
but once they land let's see what the
boys are up to
that's what the nva could be thinking
just to see what and then they knew
with those three helicopters coming in
there's a lot of people
and they wanted to maybe do their own
assessment
and see who these what who they are and
what they're up to
because um sometimes the nva just didn't
react as quickly
particularly that far west they had
never had totally
surprised at several levels surprised
that
we were there or sag was there and then
surprised at the number of aircraft
and that they actually got in
and so there's all these three different
elements
but they were you know they're checking
it out
continuing on mccarly who is serving his
second tour of duty and sog wasted no
time the company moved out in a
northwest direction
and then the men of b company had
another surprise surprise
after moving less than 400 meters from
the lz the point element of the company
reported seeing
huts the first platoon deployed two
squads to search the area
they found an enemy ammo dump 20 bunkers
spread out over 500 meters
hidden in the under the jungle canopy
with vegetation and dark
covers after setting up perimeter
security the bee company troops
pulled together a quick inventory of
what they had found picked up samples
while demolitions experts s sergeant
first class bernard bright
and specialist 5th class craig schmidt
photographed identified the weapons and
ammo and began
setting up explosive charges with 13 and
a half minute delay fuses
in the two larger structures with white
phosphorus grenades attached to each
charge to better mark
the exact location for covey who would
then direct air strikes on that position
so here we go already on the ground
already found
bad guy area but there was no bad guys
there for whatever reason
but a bunch of ammo and whatnot they
found the cash
so they're gonna blow it up
and then this happens while while the b
company team worked on this cash
mccarley had one of the most unique
moments in its 28 in his 28 years
of military service as he and a few of
the sf
soldiers were looking at a map a
telephone rang
quote i couldn't believe it a phone rang
in the middle of laos
mccarley said quote so being sf
one of our guys picked up the phone and
answered it hello
fifth special forces group may we help
you
can you imagine the reaction of the
communists on the other end of that
phone to this day just thinking about it
makes me
laugh so there you go yeah
as the sf men chuckled at the phone call
others were compiling an impressive list
of enemy weapons contained in the
bunkers
massive cache of of of weapons
not resting on its laurels b company
moved north with the platoon
with the first platoon breaking point in
a short distance the first platoon found
a trail crossed it we're proceeding
north
when a dare and second platoon squad
leader mike hagen observed
several nva soldiers on the trail and
opened fire on them
an nva 762 round went through hagen's
gas mask
which he had on his leg and slammed into
his leg so they're carrying gas masks on
this operation
bernie bright was slightly wounded the
round actually parted his hair said
mccarly
you can't get much closer than that the
nva fled the area and b company
continued to head north after
medic gary mike rose patched up hagan's
wound
as they marched they heard two large
explosions back at the nva
bunkers white phosphor white phosphorus
grenades
that brighton schmidt attached to the
demo charges emitted large plumes of
white smoke
smoke that covey readily picked up and
proceeded to direct precise
follow-up airstrikes secondary
explosions
would continue for more than five hours
can you imagine that secondary
explosions it's crazy oh
yeah yeah it's yeah it's crazy amount of
well i mean this is their supply this is
this is this is how they're fighting the
war
right there you go home and say look
what we just did yeah they'd be a great
mission
and that's the first one hour on the
ground
uh b company then made contact with the
nva
with an nva company which lasted for
close to an hour mccarley said
the hatchet force men used close air
strikes from scarface cobras and
and spads skillful squad tact and
skillful squad tactics
against the surprised nva to drive them
off as darkness approached mccarly and
the point element began looking for a
location
to remain overnight for the night
we we stopped for a combo check when
they fired one b-40 rocket into our
command post
rose added we were fortunate we were
fortunate in one small way
the rocket flew past all of us before
striking a bamboo thicket
thus when the shrapnel exploded those of
us injured didn't get the full
head-on blunt force of the metal shards
as the forward momentum of the rocket
exploded into the bamboo
45 years later after that rocket
explosion rose had one lasting mental
image of it
he says quote it's funny i can't
remember much about it
except that all of a sudden i was flying
through the air
at some point while airborne i looked up
and saw blue sky
it was beautiful and then i landed
[Laughter]
and here's mccarly rose showed us what
he was made of that day he immediately
started to go to work on the wounded
because everyone in the cp at that time
had varying degrees of wounds
in fact rose had a serious foot injury
somehow the shrapnel had sliced open his
jungle boot and cut into his foot what
did he do
he pulled out an ace bandage wrapped it
around his foot and used his car 15 as a
crutch and began treating are wounded
end quote the most serious wounded was a
south vietnamese lieutenant shrapnel
sliced into his right thigh to the bone
in addition to other shrapnel wounds we
stopped and licked our wounds as rose
past
patched up our people mccarley said
mccarley's plan was to continue to move
at night and if b
company made contact with the enemy the
special forces men would determine
whether to attack them or maneuver
around them or simply pull back and call
and fix win gunships
that could bring deadly fire from the
sky upon the enemy troops on the ground
fast forward a little bit finally rose
rigged two stretchers
from rubber poncho supported by thick
bamboo poles and tied them down with six
foot sections of rope
they would now be able to carry the most
seriously wounded indigenous troops when
rose gave mccarley the okay
bee company took the bold step of moving
out at night
quote i wasn't going to let them tie us
down in one position and then hammer us
by us moving they didn't know exactly
where we were
there were little skirmishes and a few
times we ran into a few nva
after contact we'd move on if there was
a larger element we could pull back and
call in the gunship strike
we had flare ships over us every night
end quote b company continued to march
west deeper into laos
the deeper b company green beret and
their mountain yards headed west the
more they enhanced their primary goal
of being a diversion to the nva forces
attacking the cia's
operation catapult this wasn't going to
be easy
by dawn nine of the americans
nine of the 16 americans had been
wounded so these guys have been on the
ground for
what is it they they got inserted around
noon
so we're we're talking a very short
period of time
yeah 18 hours or something like that and
they already have
nine of the 16 americans wounded
rose and his indigenous indigenous medic
koch worked tirelessly on the wounded
all night even as they moved throughout
the dark jungle
so they got they got nine wounded just
americans and they're
still moving and the two seriously
wounded uh
mounting yards yeah in stretchers and
stretchers
improvised yeah man carrying stretchers
is no joke you need to have like a team
to carry if you think if you think oh
you just get two guys one on each side
of the stretcher that works for a little
while
but you end up having to either rotate
those guys out or you put four guys on
the stretcher
it's so much harder than it looks now
luckily the yards are smaller though
right
yeah they're not like the big map man
when we when we were going through
training
and and i always be a down man the guys
would be like hey bro
well i love you bud could you go on a
diet please here
take this grenade and we'll see you
later good luck we'll mark you with a
chem light
continuing on captain gene mcardley had
the men of
b company hatchet force move moving
north well before the sun rose on day
two of operation tailwind
we zigzagged a lot during that mission
because we didn't want the nva to get a
good fix on our position as we knew
they'd try to pin us down and attack us
in force if that happened
said mccarley within an hour nva
soldiers hit the first platoon with
automatic weapons
b-40 rockets and mortars two squads
maneuvered against the enemy while
mccarley
directed airstrikes against the enemy
positions the tactics work because of
thick
jungle they weren't able to get an
accurate body count as mccarly continued
to march north
however sf medic gary mike rose knew the
casualties were climbing among both
sf and indige troops of b company
we had two yards killed and yards is the
short
the short name for mountain yards we had
two yards killed when cap mccarly and i
got hit with shrapnel from the b40
after conforming confirming they were
dead i wrapped them up
and we carried them with us as best we
could rose
said however after trying to carry them
while tending to the two most seriously
injured men
i quote i had to make a decision to
leave the two dead men behind
because i could see that carrying them
as we moved we were causing too much
fatigue for the living
so we made a decision that has bothered
me for nearly half a century
by day two it seemed as though every day
every hour i kept getting more and more
wounded
so the sf medic rose he's looking at the
situation
and we were just joking about how hard
it is to carry guys and and clearly he
he was dealing with that it's it's
it's incredibly hard and you think like
i said it takes
you have to have guys to rotate through
it's taking out a whole
lot of your combat power when you're
moving wounded
so he they probably have you know
probably takes 10 guys to move these two
wounded guys maybe even more so that's
10 guys out of the fight
and you're moving slower and so he has
to make this agonizing decision that
we're going to leave these guys
nick when i talked to mike for that part
of the story
his eyes welled up it was just like
yesterday
it really still hurt him now 50
50 years later yeah
rough
continues on here at one point during an
attack on bee company an
nva force of more than 40 enemy soldiers
two of the most seriously wounded men
that rose was treating
had both of their iv fluid bags
shattered and destroyed during a hail of
enemy gunfire
i learned a lesson right then and there
said rose we kept the ivs flowing from
low positions allowing gravity to work
but not high enough
for the enemy gunfire to destroy them
were you guys using an iv bag
were your ivs glass that's a good
question
i forget okay that's for the medics the
comma guy
yeah we well the weird thing well we all
carried ivs
right and we ended up getting smaller
ivs
but i i don't know if you he said the
ivs shattered
so that makes me think maybe they were
made of glass what the
the bags the iv bags yeah just like big
jars or what
oh no they were we for the for our
medics they had
plastic oh okay so maybe because they're
i'm not sure what the hatchet for us
yeah he took what he had yeah
that'd be my assumption
so you're treating your wounded you're
giving them iv in the freaking bags or
the jar gets shot at
yeah continuing on as the hatchet force
moved north it was obvious to mccarley
that rose had his hands full
as he continually as he had to
continually monitor two most seriously
wounded men
men who were being carried by him and
other team members and stretchers made
of bamboo sticks and panchos
because there were so many wounded
mccarly directed b company to find
or make an lz for a medevac to land
and take out the wounded they found a
large bomb crater and began preparing
the lz
when the enemy initiated two successive
contacts with them
firing small arms b-40 rockets and
throwing chai com grenades
as they work to on establishing a
clearing bee company dealt with the two
separate attacks from the nva using
squad tactics
and tac air both attacks were
neutralized only to have covey report
that the weather had turned bad
prohibiting any rescue attempts for the
day
without hesitation b company moved moved
out again going west for a while then
north keeping its pattern
of movement unpredictable
what i remember but most about day two
of operation tailwind was the
disappointment
of having the weather turn bad
preventing a much needed medevac
mccarly said so these guys have the goal
like okay we got we got some wounded
guys we need to get these guys out of
here they fight for to get it to get an
lz
once they get this lz established under
attack they push the attack back
and then the weather rolls in and the
guys can't guys can't fly
southeast asia weather is there
what's your what's your confidence on
the weather
predictions
[Laughter]
like the weather predictions in iraq are
pretty easy it's going to be hot
every once in a while you would get a a
storm
and you we we had some sand storms oh i
saw those the sandstorms they're
they're like biblical sandstorms oh yeah
they
black in the sky it's pretty cool to see
but you can't run ops in them at all
like you can't make communications
because the sand blocks radio waves so
basically if there's that kind of
biblical sandstorm coming
everyone just kind of stands down now
you could go out and try and get into a
good position
but you can't see anything you you can
see
you know maybe maybe 20 yards or
something like that i mean your
visibility's just gone
oh yeah but we could kind of know that
they were coming
i never got let me put it this way i
never got i never got surprised by the
weather
in iraq it was it was sunny
and hot 99 of the time
every once in a while there'd be some
kind of cloud maybe a little bit of
persis
precipitation by because we were by the
euphrates what river where it was
it was humid people don't know that by
the euphrates river is freaking humid
and i'm going to show you pictures
sometime of this area
to the to the northeast of the city of
ramadi it was still in our
in our ao right and it was called
uh the uh the mc1 or the one
mc but what we called it was viet ram
because because it looked like vietnam
yeah it looked exactly like vietnam
palm trees rice paddies dykes my stepson
told me about it
he was in the green zone yup yup and
he's like i thought i was back in
vietnam
with you oh was he in the green zone in
uh in afghanistan
no oh in iraq and by green zone he means
areas where there was
the we always called the green zone
which is the biggest most secure area in
iraq
okay so you're talking about the green
zone in baghdad in baghdad okay yeah
and he was operating southeast in
different
locations for near some of which they
came into iraqi jungle yep
in afghanistan they call the green zone
like areas where there's
other areas where they're like heavily
fo there's a lot of foliage right okay
so in uh in iraq the green zone is is
the green zone it's the thing right
there in baghdad which is big and secure
it's where they had good food and all
that stuff yeah we never had
any uh sandstorms in the jungle so maybe
a typhoon or two
so my question was when you would get a
weather prediction you're gonna go like
these guys let's say you were going on a
four day
mission and and they're telling you all
right
looks like the weather's good how good
did you feel about that
like did you give it 50 50. you just
figured whatever it was
figured because it could change so
quickly
but the positive thing is that if it
gets cloudy how long does that
how long are you thinking that lasts for
oh you know every time was different um
because the clouds a lot of time there
would be clouds in the morning sometimes
they burn off sometimes they wouldn't
and um there's just so much moisture
around
and um we're always juggling with the
weather
i mean that's just one of the um
factors that there's just no control we
get predictions
but um we got socked in a couple times
yeah and again they want to get us into
a hole and so okay we just go up and try
to get into a target
get in and then mother nature closes the
holes
like ah yeah we just
had to lie low and wait it out wait it
out because if you move and make
make contact there's no support and the
nva know that so they're going to really
come at you
hard if there's no air so they love it
when there's bad weather
oh sure oh yes
bad weather was the nva's ally
all right fighting the nva
fighting the weather mother nature to
fight mother nature
it's another day at sog back to the book
knight two in laos was similar to night
one b
company kept on the move with continued
support from moonbeam linking the team
with shadow stinger
and spector gunships throughout the
night
during that night we heard tracked
vehicles we heard trucks mcarley said
night two sounded like a lot of trucks
heading south bringing troops and
supplies south
and some to deal with us we had
skirmishes that night
and we directed air assets to assist us
directly
and to the areas where we heard motor
vehicle
activity so now you got the spectre gun
chips
coming at night which is a beautiful
thing well they had all three variations
because you know
you when i first get there in 68 spooky
was the first one
and then they came out with shadow
which was a c-119 whereas spooky was the
old c-47
and they could have maybe two miniguns
and
when they came out with the shadow
because we had one of our recon teams
said they came back they lived through
the night and they went through a couple
of shadows
and they had more ordinance and they
could stay on station longer
and then another team a couple months
later or maybe a year i forget the time
frame then it was the stingers
again c119s with the with the weapons
the computers the lock-in on the strobe
light and then
spectre and 50 years later you still
dominate the night
yeah that thing's a beautiful piece of
machinery
the nva also inflicted some more
casualties
in the company by the time mccarley
moved out at 4 00 a.m for day three
september 13
1970 rose was tending to more than
30 wounded men
two with deadly serious wounds that
required almost constant attention fluid
rejuvenation and pain management
by that time rose was also running low
on bandages ivs and morphine cyrettes
quote we were so low on morphine that i
reused morphine threats which is a no-no
under normal circumstances
but there was nothing normal about this
operation so i would give
two or three of the wounded morphine
from the same suret
i only gave them enough to dull the pain
but allowed them to be somewhat
alert end quote
as rose focused on the wounded the first
platoon
engaged the enemy as they moved toward a
potential lz for a much-needed medevac
while the third platoon deployed one
squad to maintain contact with another
squad of nva
attacking the company's rear after
several gun runs by scarface
and a1 skyraiders from da nang in
thailand the rear
action force rejoined the company as it
pushed
into a good lz site and began clearing
trees with claymore
mines and c4 plastic explosives
at noon after scarface and the spads
performed gun runs on
enemy positions near a small lz the
first marine corps 53-d
approached the lz as the large
helicopter descended into the lz
the pilot bill beardoll was concerned
that the lz might not be large enough to
land in
as he maneuvered the chopper slowly
downward rose moved toward the
rear tailgate of the ch-53 with his most
seriously injured soldier the south
vietnamese lieutenant with a horrific
thigh and hip injury inside the chopper
sf medics john
staff sergeant john doc paget and
sergeant john brown
moved on to the back tailgate as it
lowered with brown supporting padgett by
holding his belt
quote i was trying to reach the patient
that mike was lifting towards us
and just at that moment in time the
pilot pulled pitch and lifted to the
left
end quote rose said quote the tail rotor
struck a tree
as i was lifting the patient up towards
dock the chopper lifted
upward suddenly as it was lifting up
it took enemy small arms fire and a b40
rocket hit
end quote padgett said quote when that
b40 hit us
it went through the fuel cell but didn't
explode
there was aviation fuel everywhere how
it didn't ignite i'll never know but
surely god was riding with us
end quote bear doll pilot of the ch-53
radioed may day may day we're going in
as the ch-53 began losing fuel in its
hydraulic fuel
uh fluids yh14 that's the number of this
particular ch-53
crashed without any injuries to the
medics or crew members who immediately
exited
the wounded bird and set up a defensive
perimeter with padgett
overseeing the impromptu team on the
ground
as the ncoic for sog ccc dispensary at
khan tomb
pageant could have pulled rank and
stayed behind
and he said quote but that that wasn't
how i did things
i usually took my turn riding on the
chase medic
ship so here you have a guy that's a
senior guy
that could have been you know sitting
back in the
in the in the hooch air-conditioned in
the air-conditioned who's pooch back on
base
but he's he's not that kind of leader no
not at all steps up and gets in there
and now now these guys are getting shot
down maybe he's questioning that
decision right now oh i'm sure he was
he may not say that for the record but
doc's a smart guy
he could figure all the angles
as they set up their perimeter scarface
lieutenant h.e
newton called ch 53
aircraft number yh20 piloted by mark
mckenzie
met them at a rally point and led them
to the crash site where scarface
and spads made gun runs in preparation
for the chase medic aircraft
called sar by by the marines to arrive
for the down
downed crew and sf medics
while enroute to rescue the crew of yh14
said yh door gunner larry grow i was
admiring the beautiful countryside
and i couldn't help thinking of all the
bad guys down there waiting for us
my m60 was locked loaded and ready for
action as we got closer to the pickup
site i could see that it was surrounded
by smoke that was laid down by scar
by the scarface cobras along with their
rockets and 40 millimeters to protect
the crew of the down
chopper end quote as yh20 was about to
settle into a hover over the downed crew
an nva 51 caliber anti-aircraft heavy
machine gun
opened fire on the aircraft's left side
grows left side window was only about 25
yards away from it
and the muzzle flashes from the gun were
huge and the rounds seemed to be the
size of basketballs
grow pulled the trigger on his m-60 and
held it until the 51
cal was silenced the ch-53 started to
bounce around
and i knew quote and i knew we had taken
some hits
sergeant whitmer was working his gun on
the right side
as captain coppola and sergeant spalding
were at the rear ramp throwing out the
120
foot aluminum extraction ladder end
quote
meanwhile scarface cobras were making
gun runs
spads following suit hitting enemy sites
quote everything seemed to slow down as
the action heated up
grow said everything was in slow motion
when the ladder landed on the ground
padgett told everyone to climb in
climb it and hook onto it
there was so much confusion and noise
that no one moved to the ladder he said
finally i said follow me
and up i went they followed suit
man this is just mayhem
gross said the liftoff from the lz
wasn't easy
quote we had no idea just how bad the
battle damage was
but we were bouncing all over the sky
and we had a huge beat
meaning that the that there was
something terribly wrong with our main
rotor blades
end quote now the crew of yh20 was
concerned about the safety of the
aircraft and the men below
riding on the extraction ladder so you
have the helicopter gets shot down
and then this other helicopter comes
into rescue they get lit up with a
with a disc machine gun 12.7 millimeter
51 cal which is a freaking massive
machine gun they get shot up with that
they throw the
the extraction ladder out the back
a bunch of the guys don't know what to
do
finally someone on the ground starts
climbing the ladder they all start
climbing the ladder but they don't get
up the ladder so they're all just
hanging onto this ladder
and then this thing starts to try and
get out of there
and it's like a car with uh you know
with like a
piston that's not firing exactly
quote in hindsight there was really no
way that we or anyone else
could know could know how bad the damage
was
said grow quote only when we finally
made it back do we learn
just how bad our damage was numerous
rounds had cut the hydraulic lines to
the tail rotor
one round from the 50 cal it almost cut
the main rotor
tail drive shaft in half
that round had hit next to the thomas
coupling which connects the tail rotor
drive shaft
sections together we were extremely
lucky to have made it back to base
god was with us that day padgett said
man those helicopters are beasts to take
that kind of damage
oh yeah yeah salute
salute the 53s amen
for the rest of the men on the ground
during the night of day three there was
no rest
yeah by the way while all that's
happening we still got we still got what
a hundred and something guys left on the
ground
the nvn intensified its attacks against
the mena b company throwing an estimated
600 plus hand grenades
into the defense positions of the
hatchet force even as it moved
a few times during the night so now
we're taking 600
hand grenades
by now the b company med had gained an
important tactical advantage over
the nva i like this this is a good
attitude to have right here
we got a freaking down helicopter we got
all these wounded guy
we received 600 grenades and here you
know what
here we go by now the b company men had
gained an important tactical advantage
over the nva
they learned the nva combat signals
during the close-in fighting the nva
would hit two bamboo sticks together
or use a whistle for signals the hatchet
force
men learned that one click or one
whistle
signaled the nva to move two
meant throw hand grenades and three
meant
withdraw hatchet force men would then
radio what signal
what the signal was to the other team
members so that they could adjust
accordingly
more than once when the nva signaled to
withdraw the hatchet force men would
then attack
when they were more vulnerable it was
one more tactical advantage
that they used to their advantage
against an enemy force that continued to
grow
on the battlefield despite losing
hundreds of men to air strikes
bombing runs and team ground fire
meanwhile back in da nang at their air
base the marines returned to repair
their aircrafts as the warning order
came down for day four
the weather and nva hordes were closing
in
on bee company
because with those hand grenades one of
the things that
lynn black discovered was that the nva
had hand grenade vest where they would
have
four or five hand grenades and one vest
they could get it
and throw it forward and hold it and
then all
five grenades would launch at one time
with the pins pulled so you have
four or five hand grenades coming at you
at one time
so they were all like tied together or
something yeah
and so when they when they got the vest
and then threw it but held it
the hand grenades attached would then go
forward oh got it
and so with this thing that was going on
with the 600
plus i'm sure that was one of the
tactics the nba report
because they had the hand grenade vests
that's a lot of grenades to respond why
not
that's a lot of good even if only half
go off because they're chinese the chai
comes
but still if only half golf that's still
300 grenades yeah
and that that also tells you something
else tells you how close the enemy was
yeah because that means they're throwing
those grenades
so there's this is close fighting
and not to mention you wonder how close
it was it's so close that we can hear
their signaling when they're banging two
bamboo sticks together
primitive but effective primitive but
effective but also so close that we can
hear it and we hear it so much that we
actually decipher their freaking code
yeah god
all right going back to the book the
morning of operation tail when day four
dawned upon b
company hatchet forest of mack vsauce
moving toward an lz to lift out
the more seriously wounded among the
remaining 127 men who could still walk
all 16 green berets had been wounded at
least once
and about 40 mountain yard troops were
wounded during the first three days of
this secret foray
deep in the laos so there you go that's
at least 40
probably more because nobody nobody can
everybody's just too busy fighting
bee company commanding officer captain
gene mccarley had
the point element moving toward an
apparent clearing with one thought in
mind
get one marine corps heavy lift ch-53
helicopter in to pick up the wounded
and then continue to march to destroy
any
nva fortifications supplies or troops
they encountered
by now the entire second platoon was
being used to help care
for and transport the wounded under the
tireless leadership
of medic gary mike rose including three
wounded
who were carried on impromptu stretchers
so
there you go you have an entire platoon
of what 40 guys
yeah you have an entire platoon of 40
guys that are just being used to
for the wounded help the wounded so
that's how
hard it is to deal with wounded and move
wounded
and his maureen his morphine
cervettes are low
fast forward a little bit the men on the
ground didn't know about two startling
developments
the weather was closing in with a storm
front that would prevent tac air from
supporting bee company
and operation tail wind had rocked the
nva brass into rallying
hordes of north vietnamese and pathet
lao
troops that were moving toward the
highway 165
area near the tiny hamlet of chevain
so these guys don't know it but there's
massive enemy coming
and bad weather now when this bad
weather hits
just to be clear if i didn't make this
clear enough
the only thing that really keeps keeps
you guys alive on the ground at a
certain point is just the fact that we
have air superiority and you can drop
bombs
because they've got hundreds if not
thousands of
troops going against you so if you lose
air support it's a matter of time
because the look the the nva they don't
care they'll keep coming
they'll come in waves until they finally
just overwhelm you with the
with just attrition so if you lose tac
air
some point you're going to be overrun
and everyone's dead our edge
is gone yeah indeed
here's mccarley quote when we started
day four we hadn't thought about an
extraction except for getting the
wounded
out we took our mission seriously
meaning he's saying look we're not even
thinking about leaving yet not at all
we're thinking about getting our wounded
out but we're ready to go we're gonna
stay
we took our mission seriously relieve
the pressure on the cia's operation
thanks to tack air we had hurt the enemy
no question and by continuously moving
we had kept the nva
off balance we were tired but our morale
was good
we'd been on the move about an hour when
we heard dogs
these weren't dogs that sounded like
tracker dogs the nva used on us
they sounded like pet dogs so we moved
toward their sound
and the first platoon followed them the
dogs led bee company to what would
become one of the greatest military
intelligence coup of the eight-year
sog secret war in laos
if you're dogs they're not tracking dogs
but they're just like
pet dogs and the guys follow him back to
this camp
that's me i'm going the other way i
don't like dogs anywhere
particularly in the a.o
[Laughter]
sorry yeah no the first time i think it
was the first time you were on and we
were talking about those tracking dogs
about halfway through the conversation
after you're talking about these dogs
they're smelling you and they're closing
on you
and i was like till d do you still
like do you not like dogs and you said i
hate dogs
totally understood
before long the enemy troops fire fired
several b40 rockets at the point element
of b company and then fell back it
looked like they
had gone back to some sort of bunker
complex mccarley said
after a brief skirmish and a brilliantly
executed spad
gun runs where they had used cluster
bomb
units on enemy positions the first
platoon led the assault on those bunkers
with a well-coordinated attack while
second platoon covered our flank
and provided rear security so so you
guys these guys run up against
an enemy position with bunkers and what
do they do attack it
yeah call in for close air support and
then attack it on day four
i mean these guys probably haven't eaten
they're short on water
they're wounded
third platoon protected our right flank
we caught them napping
we hit the outpost when they were
cooking breakfast there were open
fires fires with cooking pots on them
hell they never had anyone mess with
them before this deep into laos
a few nva a few nva hitting a couple of
the bunkers
whom the mountain yards quickly
eliminated with hand grenades those
bunkers were nothing but gory blood and
guts after the grenade attacks mccarley
said
again a1 skyraider skyraiders delivered
cbus precisely along two key enemy lines
instantly silencing
enemy gunfire hand grenades and rocket
attacks
within a short period of time more than
70 nva were killed
as b companies swept through the base as
b company drove the remaining nva
out of the outpost they discovered a
bunker in the base of camp
that quote appeared to be like a
basement in a regular house
said mccarly it was at least 10 feet
long and 10 feet wide
with maps on the walls and a foot locker
loaded with documents i emptied my
rucksack of everything except for extra
car 15 ammo
by that time i had used the extra
battery radio battery and c4 that i was
carrying and i started packing with
enemy documents papers code books
transportation logs
end quote within 15 minutes the base
camp was overrun
the area was searched for intelligence
and photographs were taken
as medic mike rose continued to treat
the wounded men of the company
so this is a score that's a coup and a
half
oh yeah rich
by now it was clear to be company
intelligence men that they had stumbled
into an nv8 battalion base camp
that was a major logistical command
center and probably the headquarters
that controlled the nearby laotian
highway 165.
remaining true to his original operation
order mccarley had all the intelligence
documents packed and ordered b
company and all of its walking wounded
to march out of the battalion base camp
while demolitions experts wired 120
millimeter mortar
four enemy trucks and more than nine
tons of rice for destruction
as usual after the special forces
charges exploded
a1 skyraiders followed up with gun
napalm and bombing runs to completely
destroy
all enemy structures and supplies
boom nine tons of
rice feed a lot of people oh yeah
meanwhile back at con tomb fast forward
a little bit
meanwhile back at con tomb while all
that's happening all the air assets the
a1 skyraiders of the da nang based
operating location alpha alpha scarface
pilots
and ch-53 pilots were getting a detailed
briefing
on the weather and a sighting by covey
of hundreds if not more than a thousand
nva
and path that loud troops moving east
towards b company
quote during that final briefing it was
very clear today
it was do or die end quote from scarface
pilot joe driscoll
quote the big thing was the stark
seriousness of the moment
everyone knew they had suffered heavy
casualties and now
the weather was closing in on them a1
skyraider pilot tom
stump added quote the weather was dog
[ __ ] when we took off i wasn't
optimistic about getting them out of
their end quote
on the ground in laos mccarley pressed
forward until he received a
disturbing radio call from covey
sometime in the early afternoon of
september 14th
day four of operation tailwind quote
i believe it was covey writer jimmy war
daddy heart radioed down and told us the
nva were massing
and if that and that if we didn't get
out of there today we weren't going to
get out
period that got my attention
frankly he mentioned the weather issue
too which up to that point in time i
wasn't aware of because we were
in the jungle end quote
yeah that got your attention huh oh yeah
and
everybody back at base they know they're
getting hammered
and they know it's bad and they're
getting ready to go
they don't know how bad it is it's like
you're in the jungle like
you've heard it before you don't know
what the hell bad the weather is or
you're on the ground
and you can't tell a lot of times the
difference between sun and
no sun it's just dark in the jungle
and they break loose every once in a
while get open if they can see
right gene had no idea no idea that's
when cubby told because when i
interviewed gene on that he was like
stunned when they when cubby total night
because he really thought
we're going to kick their ass we just
hit the cash you say cash or cashier
you're the english major i'm only an
english miner
so i had a uh it's cash cash oh thank
you sir it's cash
i'll be more correct now i got corrected
that i got corrected
on that when i was a i think i was like
an e5
or something an e4 and you know i was
briefing something and i said well
there's a cachet over there yeah
my officer said actually jocko
it's cash and i said no it's not
i didn't believe him you had to go to
the dictionary and back then you
actually had to get a dictionary
yeah yeah well i'll tell you what you're
the man
if you want to call it cachet we can
change it right now
we will follow suit i've always
preferred cache me
i think it's cooler sound it could be
cash or stats but cashier's got a little
bit more
a little more pizzazz yeah
uh so these guys are in a bad way and
and now mccarley kind of
realizes we got the enemy coming we got
weather moving in back to the book
realizing they needed a large lz
a large lz large enough to handle a
ch-53 because ch-53s are massive birds
in the light of and by the way there's
no opportunity you're not going to get
50 guys
out on strings so this thing's going to
have to land yeah
and you got wounded on top of that in
light of losing one of the 53s
heavy lift helicopters on a tight lz the
previous day yeah by the way we already
lost
one of these things mccarley moved down
a road towards a clearing that was large
enough for nelsie however
the open area was seated too deeply in a
valley
which had hills on two sides of it where
the nva gunners would be able to
have clear fields of fire on the marine
rescue helicopters as well as the
supporting tack air assets
scarface uh cobra gunships to facilitate
the continued movement of b
company a1 spads and cobra scarface
scarface cobras quote gave us fire
protection to the front and to the rear
mccarly said the nva kept hitting us
with automatic fire and b-40s
the air strikes kept them back far
enough so they couldn't do any real
damage
at some point covey ran dangerously low
on fuel
returned to base and connected spad
pilot
tom stump directly with mccarly about
future airstrikes shortly before the
first
ch-53 arrived in the area of operations
quote i'll never forget it when i spoke
to gene that's mcarley when i spoke to
gene
his voice was as calm as a man at sunday
church picnic
stump said he had that slow southern
draw
and calmly said he was getting his ass
kicked down there
oh and all the while i could hear
gunfire gunfire
explosions and hand grenades
he said he needed some separation
between the company and the nva
we were on station for two hours doing
just that providing close air support
with all the sf wounded in the large
number of casualties they had
i couldn't see how we'd get them out
there you go tom stump man
uh mccarley and his men were grateful
for the close air support of stump his
fellow spad pilots scarface and tak air
but stump stood out in his mind mccarley
said quote tom stumps
flew so close to us during some of those
gun runs
i could tell if he had shaved or not
that's just how close those a1
skyraiders flew in support of us
we were extremely grateful for all the
air support believe me
but seeing stump was something to that
stuck with me
i also think it's safe to say that
because this was a sog mission deep into
laos
none of the air assets got the credit
they should have received for the
remarkable coverage they provided
to us over four days from the fast
movers right down to scarface
and the cubbies
continuing on bee company found a
heavily traveled dirt road only wide
enough for foot traffic and headed to a
second lz
one that provided better cover and less
exposure to enemy ground fire
for the helicopters and for the men of b
company
as they moved covey rider jimmy ward
daddy heart told mccarley
he had spotted another quote hoard of
nva
end quote moving toward b company
this time hart told b company to put on
their gas masks
and directed a1 sorties flown by hobo 20
and firefly 44 based in thailand to
deliver
cbu 30 tear gas ordinance on the next
hoard of nva
while bee company found and secured a
second lz for the marine ch-53 to land
this drastic tactic worked it slowed
down another
nva horde but many of the men in b
company including mccarly rose and
others were hit by the gas which had a
lot of our guys crying and choking on
that cs
mccarley said but it also bought them
some time so they called they called in
some
some uh cluster bomb units yes
with uh some coughing gas in it
some irritant indeed right which is a
lot different
this is where this is where it gets a
little tricky and it comes up later but
that is a chemical right and people say
well this is a chemical weapon
and it is technically a chemical weapon
but it's a freaking non-lethal chemical
weapon it doesn't
kill you right just you cry a lot and
feel bad
continuing on the scarface cobras led
the ch-53s into the lz with deadly
gun runs as an air force f4 phantom jets
pounded
two enemy mortar pits that were marching
82 millimeter rounds toward the lz that
was large enough for only one
ch-53 to land at a time quote we
escorted the
ch-53s into the lz the first run wasn't
as bad as the previous day
when i could see dozens of enemy
soldiers out in the open firing at us
with ch
and the choppers said scarface pilot joe
driscoll
when mccarley lost radio contact with
covey scarface commanding officer
lieutenant
colonel harry sexton and his co-pilot
pat owen
quickly picked up coordinating the air
assets
with mccarley the first heavy lift
helicopter landed on the lz picking up a
majority of the wounded be
company men including the three most
seriously wounded who were carried in
stretchers since being wounded on night
one of the operation
since platoon second platoon placed the
wounded on the first marine helicopter
before it lifted off successfully and
headed back to khan tomb
scarface again led the second marine
corps ch-53
into the lz this time taking an
increased volume of enemy gunfire
as aviators pointed out to mccarly
another large contingent of nva moving
toward the lz
now it appeared that the nva brass
realized that bee company
had hit the 559th transportations base
camp
and taken all of its maps reports
records and money
and had directed masses of enemy troops
towards b
company
quote they told me they could see
hundreds of them
coming for us said mccarly the second
marine corps
ch-53 picked up the remaining wounded
men and several other members of b
company and lifted off the lz
successfully drawing more enemy fire
than the first heavy lift
helicopter scarface then led the third
ch-50 so we got two helicopters have
come in we've gotten
most of the wounded on the first one the
a bunch of guys leave on the second one
that's all successful
and now we go scarface led the third
ch-53 into the lz
taking even more enemy fire than the two
previous choppers had encountered
however for mccarly rose first sergeant
morris adair
and the remaining men of b company the
drama
wasn't over ch 53
sea stallion pilot don first lieutenant
don persky and his co-pilot first
lieutenant
bill batty or beatty were concerned
about the amount of rounds hitting
the heavy lift chopper i like the way
they explained that yeah i'm a little
i'm a little concerned i'm concerned
about this quote on our final approach
we took heavy enemy fire persky said
we knew that this was the last element
on the ground that we had to get them
out
sergeant first sergeant or sf sergeant
mike
hagen said quote i can tell you that big
bird was a welcome sight to us
we were all beat we were all wounded and
we were all ready to go home believe me
end quote b company commander captain
gene mccarley
hagen medic sergeant rose and first
sergeant morris adair
held a tight defensive perimeter with a
few mountain yards
as others beat a hasty but orderly path
into the large marine warbird
as dozens of nva soldiers surged out of
the cs gas clouds towards the lz
macaulay was on the radio with covey he
said
you have to get out of there now this is
so this is a mccarly saying
that covey said you have to get out of
there now
there's hundreds and hundreds of them
coming after you
now now
that's what mccarly's getting told you
have to get
out of there now and i don't know how
many are left on the ground but it's
probably what 15 or 20 or something like
that
yeah because they had the worst wounded
yeah in the second bird they got a lot
of the indige out
as mccarly spoke into the prc25 handset
a mountain yard team member
standing between mcarley and the radio
operator was killed by enemy gunfire as
he fired his weapon at them
he got shot in the heads mccarley said
there was blood all over the place
another yard looked at him turned to me
with a sad look
and simply said he's dead
a1 skyraider pilot tom stump vividly
remembers those
long moments before the men of b company
boarded ch-53
quote it was a wild scene down there as
we provided
close cover to the team on the ground
air force
f-4s attacked anti-aircraft guns that
the nva had moved into the area
they meaning the nva had really
had really wanted them they were masked
to get them
they wanted to get back what the team
had taken from the base camp
covey riders told us that nva 12.7
millimeter and 37 millimeter
anti-aircraft weapons were opening up on
us
meanwhile the scarface cobra gunships
reacted to enemy gunfire on their
aircraft while gene directed us
to enemy troops moving toward them keep
in mind
we knew all the sf men were wounded and
low on ammo
there was a moment in time when i
couldn't see how we'd get them out
it was that intense
coming out of the gas fumes
not everyone was low on ammo
as he was severely wounded in the foot
hand and arm
on day one rose had tightly wrapped a
torn
jungle boot and bleeding foot with an
ace bandage to keep it shut
and had used his car 15 more as a cane
to support his weight than as a weapon
because he was so
busy treating and tending to more than
60 wounded men
his left hand had suffered a shrapnel
wound also
which he quickly wrapped before
returning to caring for the wounded team
now as he a dare hay
and hagdon or hagen moved up the ramp
the semi mobile medic opened fire on the
rapidly approaching nva
after they placed their dead mountain
yard soldier on the helicopter
mccarly was the last man to leave the lz
quote as we were backing up the ramp
they were coming toward us they were
coming at us hard he said
i'm guessing the sea ass gas had them
confused
because they were getting close to us as
me mike and
morris stood but none of them threw a
grenade into the chopper
i never understood why they didn't they
were that close
and they kept coming even as we lifted
off
from the lz while mowing down nva
soldiers
so they go through all that and it looks
like we're gonna be in a pretty good
spot possibly
but it ain't over till it's over
indeed as the ch-53
lifted off from the lz pilot persky said
he and co-pilot bat
batty what do you think that's bad of
your baby patty
batty could feel enemy rounds continuing
to hit the aircraft
adair mccarly and rose had just sat down
next to sergeant first class bernie
bright
when someone tapped rose on the shoulder
and pointed to the left door gunner
marine sergeant stevens who was bleeding
profusely from a gunshot wound in the
neck
rose said quote he got hit in the neck
there was blood everywhere
i was coated in blood by then from him
another wounded he was very lucky the
round had missed the carotid artery and
trachea
yet he was going into shock i rolled him
over
got him on all fours and remember
telling him listen you lucky son of a
[ __ ]
if you're gonna die you'd be dead by now
after that he started to bounce back
sometimes as a medic
you ha sometimes as a medic you have to
be harsh with people to break them out
of shock
then i found something to wrap around
his neck to get the bleeding to stop
as rose struggled with steven's bleeding
neck injury
neither realized that the marine door
gunner's helmet
helmet's open microphone was live so
explain this a little bit when you're on
a aircraft the people in the aircraft
have what they call interior
communications which is basically a
you know if you're the pilot you can
talk to the co-pilot and then
you can both talk to the air crew and
everyone's got these little helmets on
with microphones
and the crews in the back and they can't
see each other so they have to have
verbal cards right
and if you i know it looks like in a
movie everyone's talking in an aircraft
in a helicopter
you can't hear anything in a helicopter
you have to scream directly into
someone's ear
to hear someone especially in a ch-53
those things are freaking loud
and so the air crew has these headsets
with these microphones that are built a
special way so that they don't pick up
the
they don't pick up the external noise
they just pick up the voice well
when you key that handset you're
transmitting
you're you're filling up that interior
communications network with
whatever noise you're putting into it
and so i'll go back to the book here
communications were almost
impossible as he was on a hop mic a hot
mic is when you're keying up your
microphone when you shouldn't be
and all i could hear was gasping and
gurgling said persky who is
having a potentially deadly loss of
power issue
with the severely damaged ch-53c
stallion
as the heavily laden helicopter lifted
off from the lz and went from a hover
mode into a transitional lift
where the helicopter begins to gain both
altitude and speed
engine failure emergency lights and
warning systems screamed alerts of a
pending engine failure
within seconds one engine died
persky had only one remaining engine to
continue lifting away from the hordes of
nva gathering
on and around the lz shooting at the sea
stallion
and at least one anti-aircraft weapon
that was firing at the
struggling sikorsky in addition he and
baddie had another challenge on their
horizon
how to avoid the mountains that they
were approaching with
only one engine
that ridgeline was sheer granite persky
said
by now in the back of the chopper rose
had pulled off steven's helmet
giving persky and batty improved
communications between them and other
air assets
as the granite mountain loomed larger by
the second quote
we were worried as we had to use extra
energy from the last engine to get over
that ridgeline
persky said after narrowly getting over
it a second granite
ridgeline came into view it it too
had to be flown over now the big war
board
warbird was struggling quote there were
hydraulic fluids and blood
everywhere inside the helicopter rose
said
and the tail was lower than it should be
we could tell something was wrong really
wrong we just didn't know
how wrong
can you imagine no
no no it's uh
it's it's total mayhem and then you have
these pilots that are
getting shot at the their their
aircraft's filled up with a bunch of
wounded guys
they're taking rounds they can feel the
rounds hitting and they still have to
fly this thing
and now they got to fly it under
conditions that they've never flown
under before which is
having one engine and damaged controls
and not being able to communicate with
each other this is just mayhem
back to the book seconds after barely
getting over the second ridgeline
the second ch-53d
turboshaft engine failed
at that moment quote i can remember
first lieutenant persky's exact words to
this day
said mccarly he said mayday may day
we've lost all hydraulics were going
down
i looked out of the back and all i saw
were the granite cliffs
they loomed large to this day i don't
know how we missed them
end quote rose echoed the same sentiment
quote all i saw were that those were
those
huge granite cliffs with no engines
i fully expected to crash and burn at
any moment
end quote persky hollered into the radio
one more time
we've lost our second engine we're going
down
the fate of the 2 23 628 pound 88 foot
long helicopter designed to carry 38
combat troops but now loaded with
40 plus combat troops and weapons
including all the intelligence papers
maps foot locker
and north vietnamese currency sees from
the nva's
base camp hinged on persky's piloting
skills
and the six 72 foot long rotors that
were keeping the 15 foot wide helicopter
aloft
biting into the air descending at a
rapid rate but at a rate
better than dropping from the sky like a
dead quail
after he got out a second mayday alert
persky said he was
hoping a pilot or covey pilot would say
something
after a second engine went out there was
nowhere to go
all we could see was jungle and granite
ridgelines
quote i really expected someone covey
scarface the spads or army cobras to say
hey go left go right something but the
radio was dead
silent for persky and batty the silence
was deafening
now descending in full auto rotation
with both
engines dead persky began following
jungle covered canyons i followed one
gap he said then i followed a second gap
it led to a ravine
my biggest concern at that moment was
being able to find a place just to auto
rotate into
marine corps door gunner larry grow who
was in the first ch 53
that pulled out many of the wounded men
from b company earlier
said quote at that time no one had ever
done
a full auto rotation with a fully loaded
ch-53 with no power
swanson watched the large war bird
descend
into a canyon quote it was like a
depression
he headed towards it was trailing smoke
it was ugly real ugly i worried that it
might explode in mid-air
or worse get hit by one of the or worse
hit one of those granite mountains or
the jungle
from my seat up in the old trusty
skyraider
i couldn't see any lz or any area that
was open or large enough for those
marines to land
that bird without crashing by now i had
heard
that they were auto rotating with a
chopper full of troops
it didn't look good
so auto rotating yeah
so basically when a when a helicopter if
a helicopter loses power
you know if an airplane loses power you
can glide
somewhat you're not going to gain
altitude i mean i guess you you could
technically if you're getting a if you
get an updraft or current or whatever
but you're generally going to come down
when a helicopter loses all of its power
what the what the pilot has to do is let
the
blades the rotor blades of the
helicopter keep spinning
as fast as they can while you're falling
and then basically when you get
close to the ground you slam those
things
into the position it tilts those rotors
so they grab as much air as possible
in the moment before you hit the ground
and you hope that it absorbs enough
energy that you don't all die
echo you look puzzled does that make
sense
not really i think there's a lot about a
helicopter i don't
know about i think because you're like
it seems like a helicopter loses power
the the
the propellers just stop but there's
momentum so just pictures
[Music]
keeps the blades going all right like
descending and the air hits them
and keeps them they have their angles
that make them spin
yeah with the engine so it slows down
but it's better than like
he said just falling out of the sky
right like those you know remember those
windmills he used to buy when you're a
kid and you
you you seen him saying you know the
wind yeah okay if you went into a room
with no wind and you just spun that
thing
yeah it would it would spin a little bit
but yeah as you move it
yes so that's got those things spinning
and remember yeah yeah and you know that
the blades can tilt
you control the tilt of the blades you
can make them kind of flat
or you can make them like at a bigger
angle so they're grabbing more air
so what you do is you kind of make them
flat so they're not getting much
resistance but they're spinning
and this is just like i'm never talking
about version
gotcha yeah this is how i simplify stuff
with the rocks up in my head
and then when you get close to the
ground you slam that thing so it grabs a
bunch of air
right before you hit and it slows you
down a little bit that's the plan
yeah that's the plan and in history
no one had ever done this before with a
c
with a ch 53 okay filled with
troops because as you can imagine you're
adding thousands of pounds to it
with all these troops in there so no
one's ever done this before
so we'll just say that the odds were
stacked against us
at this point it ain't looking good okay
okay gotcha
continuing on and then divine
intervention
persky and batty saw a body of water
with a little patch of beach it was just
blind luck we didn't know what was there
or we didn't know what was there or god
was with us
persky said with the blood hydraulic
fluid and aviation fuel leaking and
pooling in the passenger compartment
persky headed in that direction at first
he thought about landing in the water to
buffer some of the impact of the landing
then i remembered persky said we had
wounded in the back i didn't want to
take the chance of anyone drowning
so he headed the wounded chopper toward
what appeared to be a sandy beach next
to the water
even though it was slanted to the right
all this happened in a matter of seconds
we were going down at about six thousand
feet a minute
at that point we needed high airspeed to
use the energy to keep the rotors going
so the auto rotation factor would keep
the aircraft moving forward instead of
dropping from the sky
the plan was to flare a procedure where
the rotor's angle
pitch is changed to slow down the rate
of descent and minimize the severity of
impact upon landing on terra
firma so i was right yeah the rocks
worked
the rocks worked dave burke's got
nothing on me
good deal
quote i started to flare thinking we had
enough time to decrease our speed more i
pulled the collective hard i had it
pulled up to my armpit
end quote in a helicopter the collective
lever is on the left side of the pilot's
seat
and it changes the pitch angle on the
helicopter's main rotors in this case
persky was decreasing the sea stallion
speed
hoping to minimize the final impact of
landing in full
full auto rotation persky added it
didn't slow our air speed as much as i
had hoped it would
it was supposed to cushion us it didn't
what's more
that beach had a huge boulder on it that
slanted to the right
the helicopter violently landed on the
angled slope
hitting the slope surface and instantly
slamming to the right into the ground
ejecting several of the
green berets and their mountain yard
tribesmen
team members while six rotors shattered
upon
impact with the ground
bee company commanding officer captain
gene mccarley was violently slammed into
the roof of the helicopter before being
ejected from it
i remember hitting the roof of the
helicopter i remember hitting so hard
i felt my teeth crumble into sand
the next thing i knew i was outside on a
rock we were all dazed
amazed we were still alive rose said
quote
when you pancake in like we did on a
helicopter
and when it hits violently upside down
everybody had their bell wrong
trust me we were all hurting gene was
bleeding from the mouth but he could
move
i remember getting thrown out of the bl
throating thrown out and the blades were
upside down
i was bleary-eyed still not getting all
my senses back and for a moment i
thought the chopper was coming toward me
end quote mccarley said quote
mike was standing beside us i was wiping
the blood and my crushed teeth from my
mouth then mike said
we've got people in there we have to get
them out
i could smell the aviation fuel there
was blood everywhere there was hydraulic
fluids
the helicopter was broken by the
severity of the crash and it was smoking
how it didn't explode i'll never know
how that young marine pilot landed
albeit a hard landing i'll never know
end quote then
mccarley had one of those unique
inexplic inexplicable moments
in wartime in the middle of all the
rubble the smoke the dazed confusion at
the crash site
he looked to his right and observed
first sergeant morris adair
standing in the water with a smile on
his face
holding his car 15.
in the middle of the jungle that scene
was
unreal beyond description mccarley said
of all the times that i've been in laos
i'd never seen a scene like this a body
of water a nice white sandy beach it
looked just like hawaii
and there's a dare standing in the water
as though there wasn't a care in the
world
adair says to this day i can't explain
explain exactly what happened that day
i came out on my own but i've been
trying to figure out how ever since
when i came to my senses i was standing
in water gene told me later i was
standing there smiling
can't tell you why i was smiling maybe i
was just happy to still be alive after
getting my bell wrong
we were batted around like bbs in that
chopper when it crashed at the time
i didn't realize how much damage had
been done to my nerves on my left side
of my body
my head neck shoulder arms and hip
the brief reverie ended when rose and
mcarley headed back
into the smoking helicopter because it
ain't over yet because they got guys in
there
and it's get fuel leaking everywhere
burning but what do they do they go help
rose helped to carry out
sf lieutenant pete landon who had only
been in
country one week when operation tailwind
launched welcome to sag
mccarly said landon the platoon leader
had a bad gash on his head that rose had
to tend to
as there was a lot of blood flowing from
the head wound mccarley gathered the
intelligence materials
b company had collected that was the
first thing i did recover the intel
documents maps currency
that we had seized from the nva base
camp no way we were going back to
contour without them
after setting up a hasty perimeter
at the rear of the broken sikorsky
helicopter mccarly returned to help
sergeant first class bernie bright get
untangled from the wires and debris
inside the aircraft
then they exited the helicopter to
strengthen the perimeter
around the back side of it in the
pilot's compartment persky
unstrapped baddie who had pulled a bad
back compression
stemming from the crash i kind of pulled
bill from the helicopter he was mobile
but still stunned
when persky set batty down on the ground
in front of the helicopter
he didn't see any sf men on that side of
the bird
my infantry tactics kicked in we circled
the wagon set up a rough perimeter
he said persky said
in the back of the helicopter rose
mccarley and mike hagen
helped the stunned troops exit the
helicopter
quote before i'd let any of the injured
get off the helicopter i draped their
weapons or
any weapon near them around their neck
so that when they set up in the
perimeter
they'd be able to defend themselves said
rose by this point in time
we were strictly working on adrenaline
he added so even those guys
these guys have been through all this
freaking mayhem yeah
and they still go back and rescue their
guys and then they're still thinking
tactically about how to get through this
yeah mike rose is on top his game for
that whole thing just amazing
continuing on once again time was
working against the men on the ground
i forget how long it took from the time
we crashed until i received radio
contact from either
lieutenant colonel sexton or covey said
mccarley
they told him that the backup
helicopters fuel levels were getting low
and that when he came into the lz we'd
only have
five minutes or less to get the hell out
or we might not have enough aviation
fuel to make it back
after dodging russian assisted nva
attack
aircraft weapons including russian
manufactured
akkak weapons that exploded in mid-air
in the fashion of anti-aircraft
weapons in world war ii and hundreds of
enemy
ground forces firing automatic weapons
and rapid rocket-propelled grenades at
them pilots in the first scarface
cobras that led the rescue helicopter
toward the lz were surprised to receive
no enemy ground fire the heavy lift
marine sea stallion followed closely
behind the scarface gunships
due to the heavy enemy ground fire
throughout operation tailwind
to provide extra defensive firepower for
the big helicopter
captain h capola
what do you think coppola captain h
coppola was on the rear
ramp with an m60 machine gun in addition
to
right door gunner sergeant t mcbride on
the left
door gunner sergeant t wennicki
and crew chief sergeant smith
even though we had our bell rung when
that
chase ship backup helicopter landed we
didn't waste any time getting aboard it
said mike rose i remember hagen gene
first sergeant helping me helping people
up the ramp
marine pilot persky knew that he had
bitten through his lip upon the crash
impact but he didn't realize how
severely damaged it was
until he moved up the ramp of the ch-53
and one of the door gunners pointed out
that his lower lip was merely hanging on
by a thin piece of skin
quote he told me that i better hold on
to my lip or i'd lose it
i do remember they changed my call sign
afterwards
to lip as the sea stallion lifted off
with the wounded and extremely fatigued
men of bee company rose made another
surprising discovery
maggots had helped to treat the two most
seriously wounded team members who had
been carried since
day since the command post was struck by
an rpg round
during day one when that rpg hit
rose had suffered serious wounds in two
places mccarly in several places
and two indige team members had been
seriously incapacitated
the one thing i never thought about or
planned for said rose
was for the use of maggots which in the
end proved to be the most
likely lifesaver for the two most
critically wounded team members
during those four days on the ground
rose and the monyard
medic trainee koch were kept busy caring
for them giving them extra fluid
morphine shots and ivs but during those
days
quote flies laid their eggs in the
wounds of the most seriously injured
and a few other yards and the eggs
hatched according to the doctors at the
evacuation hospital
the maggots got to the necrotic flesh
before
infection could set in and in fact did a
better job of debriding the wounds than
a surgeon could do
who would have thought of it we we
covered a book where that happened with
the prisoner war camps in um
in in um
world war ii yep they would act that the
medics would actually utilize
maggots they would get them to plant uh
their their
their maggots there get the flies to
plant their seeds there
so to eat away the dying skin
crazy oh yeah
the ch-53 returned to dak ii to refuel
while the a-1 pilots swanson and stump
destroyed the crashed
ch-53 the rescue sea stallion then
returned b
company to the lz outside the top secret
sog
compound in khan tomb an s2 officer
approached mccarly and took his rucksack
which contained the enemy currency
and some of the intelligence documents
collected from the nva command post in
laos
i never saw that rucksack again nor the
nva currency again mccarley lamented
he continued regardless the mission was
dubbed a success by the folks in saigon
and at sog headquarters we were told
that thanks to our efforts
the cia's operation was able to regain
control of the strong point
atop the plateau 10 days after we were
extracted
on the final helicopter we had tied down
an estimated
regiment of nva and pathet lao forces
while destroying one major enemy ammo
dump and an
enemy base camp after we removed the
enemy documents and maps
a subsequent dod report confirmed
mccarley's final analysis that operation
tailwind
was sogg's deepest penetration into laos
during the eight year secret war
the final count three mountain yards
were killed in action
33 were listed as wounded in action a
total of 33 purple hearts were awarded
to the 16 green berets who served in
operation tailwind
for wounds they reserved during the four
day wounds they received during the four
day mission
mccarley required nine months of dental
repair and surgery due to crashing
crushing his teeth
when the ch-53 crashed
two days after the green berets returned
to ccc
completed their reports and got patched
up by special forces medics on base
a huge party was held in contour base
with food soda and alcohol for all the
participants
in operation tailwind including the
aviators
from the hmh 5463 unit
scarface cobra gunship crews army cobra
gunship crews
and some air force covey pilots somehow
the word did not get delivered to the a1
spad
pilots and ground crews from the danang
base
47 years later swanson mused quote
it's just as good that we didn't get the
word because we were busy supporting
other sog and sar missions you know
just another day in the prairie fire
area of operations for our skyraiders
end quote to this day rose can't touch
the thumb on his left
hand with his little finger due to the
serious nerve and muscle damage he
received
when wounded on day one on day one
yeah so all that
medical treatment he provided with no
thumb in action
for more than two years his wife pulled
pus coated shrapnel and bamboo shards
from his body stemming from the many
times
he was hit with shrapnel while on the
ground
a dare still suffers from nerve damage
to his neck left shoulder
and arm from operation tailwind
but what's crazy is no green beret is
killed in action
that's that's amazing to recall
oh yeah
that's just a it's an incredible i mean
it's a beyond incredible operation
it is so successful in so many levels
and the uh the fact that the hordes were
coming
by day four they finally reacted when
they reacted
it was enough to take the pressure off
the cia operation so they were
missing accomplished with the bonuses of
hitting the
command center and then the other cache
where they blew up with
tons of rice weapons trucks etc
yeah the the fireworks went on for quite
a while
and wipe out a base camp in his spare
time yeah
oh amazing and the i mean just the
the the mission focus
mccarly just to get you look we get shot
at while we're
while we're on insert yeah yep we're
still going we
get contacted we're still going we get
wounded we're still going we get more
wounded we're still going
we find an enemy base camp are we gonna
are we gonna back away no we're gonna
attack it
yeah we're gonna keep going he's
relentless totally relentless
classic example of a guy learned from
the ao
applied in the field and do it at such a
level
no always changing direction so the nba
wouldn't be sure where they're going
and moving at night at night you guys
didn't move much at night normally
recon we never did a couple guys may
have gotten away with that but not
us no when we were night we we hunkered
down
and they had good enough weather that
they could uh
click in with you know spectre
shadow stinger um and uh it made a
difference
and we may have downplayed it because
gene everybody couldn't even
remember how many gunships they went
through at night but every night they
went through they used some
yeah seals moved at night during vietnam
that was that was like one of the things
that they did that was like
outside the box you know was they
that's what that's one of the things
that they did was they moved at night
i don't know how they did it but they
did it yeah
um now you kind of you kind of referred
to this earlier
um these guys do this beyond heroic
operation of course
no one ever hears about it because it's
sog and you you guys all signed a
20-year
uh you know oath of silence on this
stuff
and all the air crews were told before
they went in
everybody you know of course they won
uh skyraider people they there's an sop
with them
but there's a lot of new troops coming
in with the
helicopter crews the cobra gunships
even though they you know scarface had
been doing
uh the fence missions for a long time
they were all briefs
when we're done here you don't talk
about it yeah and and
we kind of breezed through it but also
uh you heard mccarly say that i think it
was mccarly say that
because it was so secretive these a lot
of these pilots they didn't get any
recognition at all
i mean you're freaking flying a
helicopter into an lz
where there's massive machine gun fire
to extract guys i mean that's just
insane bravery right and you know again
the beauty of talking to people
after you write the book when i talked
to tom stump
and gene on that one point when they
were together we had a
a reunion a a tailwind reunion a few
years ago
in tennessee and there
gene mccarley said had you not done that
we would have been done right then and
because they were really up against
the wave attacks by that point and
they're lowering ammo
and tom stump he said you literally
saved our ass right there
and he came through the clouds somehow
these a1 piles
and tom stump those guys how they get
through the clouds
to get down to be critical mass danger
close
and to save their ass i mean
and they're just wonderful we just love
them that's why we feel like the
skyraider pilots were saints
yeah the the seals had a relationship
like like that with the uh
with the sea wolves the the navy
helicopter pilots
and we've had a couple of sea wolves on
here and and uh
freaking badass same thing say they were
going
like if they got the call they were
going that's all there was to it
scramble to see well it's all right cool
what do you got we're going to get you
out and the sea wolf history is
they were kind of like treated like
steph curry oh for sure they had to go
out scrounge stuff for a short time and
yet when it came time those guys flew
and they were good yeah they're another
legend
yeah absolutely man freaking heroic oh
yes
so these guys do this heroic operation
and you mentioned this earlier
and i'm going to go to the book 28 years
after one of the most successful
operations run in the 1970
run in 1970 during the eight-year secret
war operation tailwind
cnn that's the cable news network
broadcast a disgraceful erroneous story
that stained the reputation of the men
who participated in that mission
portraying them as war criminals
instead of reporting the facts of the
successful mission cnn accused the green
berets and airmen of gassing american
pows
held captive in laos with deadly sarin
gas
cnn used that error-laden net work of
fiction in an effort to compete with
cbs's
popular 60-minute program when it
launched a new program on
june 7 1998 called newsstand the title
of the bogus
slanderous story entitled
valley of death it alleged that 16 green
berets and 120
indige troops from operation tailwind
had destroyed a village and killed
innocent women and children
while directing u.s aircraft to drop
lethal sarin nerve gas on u.s war
defectors they said were pows of the
communists
to compound the egregious attack against
america's finest soldiers and airmen
the next day time magazine repeated
the hideous allegations in the news
story written by cnn staff members
headlined did the u.s drop nerve gas
it was written by cnn producer al april
oliver
and cnn international correspondent
peter arnett who produced the cnn story
that aired june 7th the broadcast
and time article smeared the men of
operation tailwind
which was conducted during the
eight-year secret war in laos during the
vietnam war and run under the ages of
military assistance command vietnam
studies and obsturation group or simply
sag
[Applause]
there was an additional political
ramification stemming from the cnn
time magazine report in 1998 at a july
21 1998 press conference repudiating the
cnn time report
then secretary of defense william cohen
said quote
the charge would be used to discredit
the united states attempt to curb the
proliferation peripheral nation
of weapons of mass destruction in fact
iraq
immediately incorporated cnn's charges
into its anti-use
anti-us propaganda effort to try and
deflect attention from its own
outlawed chemical and biological weapons
programs end quote cohen ordered a
full-scale across-the-board
investigation of the cnn time story
from all military branches involved in
operation tailwind
while requesting at the same time from
the cia and the joint chiefs of staffs
of course these guys found up you know
reported what had really happened
and then there's some retractions and
some apologies
secretary cohen said i think all
americans should know that the 16 men
who conducted this mission were heroes
but that that they had been have been
hurt by this report
i can assure you that you and your
colleagues and your families
you did nothing wrong and he's obviously
he's addressing the the men
quite to the contrary you did everything
right 16 americans fought steadily for
four days
all of them were injured all got out
alive the documents that they captured
provided intelligence bonanza
general abrams the commander of our
troops in vietnam said tailwind
was a valuable operation executed with
great skill and tremendous
courage cohen told reporters that after
rigorous review of
thousands of pages of document
statements and after action reports
the military ordinance and weapon
storage records quote we found no
evidence to support cnn
time assertions we have found absolutely
no evidence to support these charges
cnn and time retracted their reports
noting
that they could not support either
charge
on july 2nd 1998 in a cnn retraction
cnn news group chairman president and
ceo tom johnson
said an independent investigation
concluded that the report
cannot be supported there was
insufficient evidence that sarin or any
other deadly gas was used
and cnn could not confirm that american
defectors were targeted
at the camp as newsstand reported
we apologize to our viewers and to our
colleagues at time for this mistake
cnn owes a special apology to the
personnel involved in operation tailwind
both the soldiers on the ground and the
u.s air force pilots and u.s marine
corps helicopter pilots
who were involved in the action
on july 13th time magazine printed an
apology to its readers
headlined tailwind and apology
they noted that the allegations reported
on june 7 8 1998 could not quote be
supported by the evidence
end quote in july 14 1998
ted turner wrote a letter to mccarly
quote i hope you'll accept my personal
apology for the cnn
newsstand's recent erroneous reporting
on operation tailwind
this entire episode has been very
painful for me as the founder of cnn
however my greatest distress comes from
knowing that our coverage upset those on
the front line
of operation tailwind the soldiers on
the ground and the u.s air force and
marine
corps pilots engaged in the accident end
quote mccarley said in a 2015 interview
quote i personally spoke to ted turner
and he reiterated that he wrote what he
wrote in the letter
he also told me he was going to call the
other members of our team and write them
a letters of apology
to my best to the best of my knowledge
that did not happen
end quote larry grow a marine corps
helicopter door gunner
who survived operation tailwind added i
felt really betrayed by cnn
for allowing those reporters to publish
all those lies and twisting the
statements
from those who were interviewed cnn
showed me
how the news media can twist a story to
fit its needs
and have never really trusted any of the
other media 100
in their reporting since then
interviewed in 2016 retired air force
lieutenant colonel mel swanson who is
the commanding officer of the daring a1
skyraider pilots
remained brutally bitter about cnn's
false story
quote operation tailwind was the classic
example of
inter-service cooperation in that area
of operations
think about it america's finest the
green berets and their loyal troops
kicked ass and took numbers on the
ground deep in enemy territory
the tactical air support from the air
force fast movers
c-130 gunships our beloved ah
a1h spads in combination with marine
corps scarface cobra gunships armory
army cobras
and marine corps dimmers raised hell in
the enemy's backyard
we killed hundreds of these commie
bastards and thanks to the
that green beret medic all were kept
alive until
the final extraction when one mountain
yard soldier was killed
until 1998 i occasionally watched the
communist news network but after they
ruined our reputations
i never watched it again it was a crime
against our warriors what they did
it was a travesty of justice
amen yeah i mean
obviously right now we're living in a
you know this is 1998
and and the media is even more um
uh partisan and they take stories all
the time and run with these stories and
and a lot of times it's it happens so
much that it's
we forget what it does to the actual
people that are victims of the stories
these false stories that come out and so
you know you get a situation like this
these guys and you know you know i was
thinking about
you know uh uh mike rose
who who had to make that decision out in
the jungle that he's gonna leave
you know his his his indige troops out
there that were dead he's leaving the
bodies
and he's tore up over that for for his
whole life since then oh absolutely and
then you get a story like this comes out
it's um yeah it's a travesty and they
knew it was coming
so i mean they knew there was a story
coming but they didn't know it's going
to have that negative edge to it
and the distorted inaccuracies so
some of these guys lined up their
fountains sit down in front of the tv
mike hagen and and mike rose were two
others that come to mind right away
because they
had their families hey we're going to be
on cnn tonight
and then halfway through the broadcast
when that true tone comes out
and the founder looks out like you were
criminals
and and then mike had to explain to his
daughter yeah
mike rose and he was just
devastated and he had to sit there and
try to explain it and these kids see
things on tv
tv is never wrong and look at dad with a
little bit of cross eyed but
horrible impact on a personal level
nobody ever hears about
um
you you you alluded to this earlier
because the secrecy
of sog and what you guys were doing
there's a bunch of reasons because the
secrecy of sog
because the number of guys that were uh
doing turnover so you've got guys coming
in and leaving
and then the number of guys that are
wounded the number of guys that are
killed
the number of guys that are missing
there's a lot of
sog operators that as as we mentioned
earlier
never met the pilots that were
supporting them
and so you'd get these guys they'd never
see them yeah
um but then and you again you alluded
this to this earlier in 2016 going to
the book the first
operation tailwind reunion was held at
the tennessee museum of aviation
bringing together for the first time in
more than 45 years
some of the men from all of the aviation
units and some of the special forces
soldiers
from that unique mission featuring b
company commander
gene mccarley the commanding officer of
the a1 skyraiders
mel swanson and the pilots who flew
marine corps cobra gunships
from scarface the ch-53 pilots and a few
forward air controllers
with tears in his eyes swanson said i
hope this is the first of more reunions
like it
to see how grateful the men of saug were
for our support during those
hairy prairie fire missions touches me
through and through
as well as the other pilots here today
we always wondered
who those crazy [ __ ] on the ground
were and now thanks to the
reunions and this reunion we get to meet
them and i can't tell you how much this
means to me on a personal level as a
as the commander who sent our a1 pilots
into harm's way every day
to learn how much they appreciated us in
the ao it's gratifying beyond words
scarface pilot barry pensic am i saying
that right
panchik pensic pencey
scarface pilot barry pencic told the
audience
that when the marines went across the
fence
into laos quote they made us change our
call sign for some reason
they called them mission 72 when we went
across the fence
whenever we ran a mission 72 for some
reason they had
us take off our dog tags leave our
wallet at home so you couldn't be
identified
as if you go down in an american made
helicopter and you're a white
round right guy round eye in an asian
country and no one's gonna know you're
american
i never understood the logic of that
then in a in a closing note
pen pencil turned to the audience and
apologized to the ladies in advance for
contaminating the spoken word with
profanities
to summarize the time he spent during
that operation
i can't think of another way to say this
he said apologetically
for example if someone is really good
he's a hot [ __ ] if something
was good it was [ __ ] hot if you get into
a bad situation it was a [ __ ] sandwich
don persky mentioned the sandwich we got
into earlier
if you had your act together you had
your [ __ ] together
and i would like to say that i was
honored to have a week or so to spend
with all these people
here and a bunch of others and that they
were a bunch of hot [ __ ]
guys on a [ __ ] hot mission and then we
got into a [ __ ] sandwich
but we had our [ __ ] together in the end
no [ __ ] airborne
[Music]
is that a great line or that is a great
line
that is a great line um
so you know one one thing i want to
mention um is that
mike rose in on october 23rd 2017
received the the medal of honor oh yeah
um
at the white house at the white house
for president trump
and it shows you that you know even
though it wasn't known about at the time
the heroism of these guys was just
well that's the highest honor that this
person can be
can receive so
salute to those guys and and man
what a mission now i'm going to jump
ahead and look we're
we're not covering all of sod chronicles
by the way that was one mission
to cover in this volume one assad
chronicles um
but one of the things that i when i
started reading i read a quote that said
you know as of
june 13 2017 there were still 50 green
berets listed as mia
in laos alone along with at least 105
aviators who died supporting sog
missions
they are among the total of
approximately 260 av
aviators missing missing in laos as of
this printing now
there's a uh there's a story in here
and i don't i don't want to go through
the whole thing um
because people should get the book and
read through it
but on a high level because it ties into
the
the um you know this the mias that are
still out there
can you tell us a little bit about rt
intruder
and and and what happened on that on
that operation oh sure
um they went into the target
and um made enemy contact and uh they
had to get pulled out on strings
so the first helicopter came in pulled
out the first half of the team
rt intruder the second helicopter came
in again with strings to pull them out
and they had two americans
three americans are on on the strings
and maybe one in the ditch i forget
about the endanger
and as they're lifting off one of the
ropes got tangled in the trees and sami
hernandez
fell to the ground was knocked on
conscious so he's unconscious
helicopter continues up gets hammered
turns around spins out of control and
then
crashed into a granite wall or to a
mountain
killing the entire air crew everybody on
the ropes
so the next day uh the bright light goes
in
and maybe a day or two days later
the bright light goes in they get to the
crash site
and they're able to recover all the
bodies
sammy hernandez during the night woke up
played hide-and-go-seek with the nva he
found a uh
found a cave or some kind of area where
he could get out of the way
and before he went into the cave he his
shoulder was dislocated
so he pounded his shoulder back into
place on a tree
then he hid for the night in the morning
at first light
covey came by and he had his panel and
they were able to extract him out
they came in with a bright light got all
the bodies
put them into body bags moved them to a
location i forget they got to the top of
the mountain or not
but cliff newman was on that mission and
they went in put together all the bodies
but it was too dark they couldn't come
in and get them out that night
the plan was in the morning they'll come
in early well in the morning before
any aircraft could get there any air
cover the nba hit that team
hard and bottom line they couldn't get
the bodies out
they literally left them there
um 35 40 years later cliff newman goes
back
in an effort to work with our
what's now dpaa department pow mia
accounting agency and it was the
predecessor but cliff went in
tried to find it the cooperation with
the
um indigenous people
forget with the laotians or the
vietnamese they put them in too far away
from the mountain
they so cliff went back four or five
years ago
again the second time and again they're
too far away
so cliff is waiting for the third call
to go back
and uh try to help him and this is the
dedication of cliff
and uh sammy hernandez is still alive
and of course cliff newman was
and sammy were on the first team that
did the first
halo jump in the layoffs well that's
one of the other reasons why i don't
want to go too much deep detail right
now because hopefully
we get them on here to tell the story oh
he'll come back
yeah you know when you you think about
that you know i just was looking through
um some of this information uh americans
unaccounted for
in southeast asia right now
um total of 1580
and post january 1973 they've
repatriated 1059
from vietnam china laos and cambodia
so we still have work to do there
to get these guys back home yeah and
even on that missionary
um the morning that they went in to get
to be to pull the recon team out after
the recon teams hit
we had a cubby that went in and got shot
down
and they lost all of everybody's killed
and they um they couldn't get them out
right away
but eventually i think it now would be
maybe 10 years ago they got
the pilot out they recovered his body
and um so today yeah the 1508
remaining mias in southeast asia
which includes vietnam laos cambodia
and china and there were a few up there
um piles mostly i assume and uh
september 18th will be the pod national
pow mia recognition day when uh there
will be
events held across the country and of
course you have the iconic plwma flag
that that's now been authorized by
president trump to be flown all federal
buildings
throughout the year now every day trying
to keep attention focused
at that level
anything that we can do to help out on
that stuff
um well there's a lot of issues attached
to it but the most important thing is to
keep
keep people writing their congressman
and say please keep the efforts going
forward on this for the
for the americans for southeast asia
because
what's working against us in addition
mother nature again
is the most acidic soil in the world
eventually eats up bones and maybe teeth
and so um who knows how much longer
the remains will be and
you know for my case like spider pat
watkins
lynn black the mias the people we knew
who are our teammates that are now part
of that
and we still hope to someday at least
get the remains back
someday maybe not i think there's going
to have to be somebody
somewhere it's going to say we have to
end it but
until they do um the what's really
amazing the young teams that they get
out there from dpa
they're dedicated these kids go out
their army
marine corps they usually take a medic
an sf medic
with them now and these kids are
dedicated they really do a great job
we'd like to see a little bit more
coming from mid management
at dpaa in terms of the commitment
it really pushed this thing keep it in
the public's eye
and and that president trump's been
supportive of it and um
that's all we can do we're at the uh
we're at the mercy of uh
time here and the efforts yeah i know i
know they would send guys
i know guys in the seal teams friends of
mine that would go to vietnam
to support those operations oh yeah
it's it's like there's no inter-service
ride over here
for all americans no matter what service
and there's been
teams that have gone in for over 40
years now
you know i forget the exact date but if
uh
i think it's june you know they they
always stop to talk about the aircraft
that was a
jpeg aircraft loaded with people going
for a mission
that crashed and we lost several
americans
as well as indigenous people working
with us on that
so it's a deadly mission it's been a
long battle and do you have the
a the national pow mia
family league of families national
league of pow mia families have been
fighting this war
the effort to bring home identify
bring home the remains of many americans
we can
and did they were the first people
in any war we fought that demanded that
the enemy
treat our prisoners better during the
vietnam war
and then they had another name i forget
what it was but then they initially
became eventually became
the national league of power m.i.a
families the director
ceo is ann mills griffith she and
her father started when her brother went
down in september
of 66 as a navy backseater in f4
and uh that family's been involved ever
since
and she had been involved when the
league was
formally found in 1970 50 years of this
effort
dedicated to non-profit and they're down
and she fights our government
she knows is respected by all the our
prior enemies laos cambodia north
vietnam they all know her
they know the league and they work with
dia very closely
and who do we look up where do we go to
try and give them support
uh the national league of pow mia
families if
um just google and it pops right up and
mills griffis is the
director ceo just amazing
tough strong relentless woman she's been
through three husbands
and but the admission never stops she
just continues to go seven days a week
she works on this stuff it's just an
amazing story
well salute to her and obviously um a
salute to all these
all these all these that lost all these
intermission in action and
man these stories are
unbelievable
well i know you and i have some plans of
trying to get
as many of these things captured as we
can um
i know you're traveling and you you
might start you know
might get some training from uh echo
charles and how to press record on one
of these things
absolutely and get these things you know
everyone wants to hear as much of these
stories as we can
so hopefully we can get that going we've
we left some space
on these last couple podcasts if if if
blackjack wants to come on
if uh yeah if sammy wants to come on the
the it's always open the door is always
open here
this is the this is the most friendly ao
that sog has ever known right here in
this podcast space
again the trouble is like with you and
your your fellow seals
it's these guys are so damn humble i
mean even i had to pull quotes out of
them
yeah and work at it but i will i promise
i'll go back to cliff and those guys and
sammy he's just an amazing guy he lives
down in texas
and just goes on to live he came back
and
did his time in the service a career
soldier
um just a remarkable man and we got one
king bee pilot we were working we got
targeted yeah indeed
we're talking to captain on and he
hasn't responded yet
okay but when he responds well i hope we
can get him in because uh
he's in both the books yep yeah and uh
so and his stories are
well every king be part any of that is
still alive
and you know uh sadly in june i attended
the
funeral for captain tuang who saved my
ass on our team bacon so many times i
couldn't even count that many
particularly on christmas day of all man
yeah those guys um yeah i was i was
reading through one of these where
these guys were just uh was that captain
tuang who would go in
but or was it captain ahn who went on by
himself
by himself hey it's too dangerous
co-pilot get out air crew get out yeah
i'm going by myself to go and rescue
these guys so
we're getting overnight yeah getting
overrun yeah
what that's just freaking
awesome and heroic so hopefully
it'd be an honor to have him on here and
talk to him
and uh hear hear about his life story so
we will do that and and those king bee
polls well even our americans i mean
these young kids that were flying these
helicopters so
fearlessly and amazingly i mean they how
did they get
ice cubes in their blood would be so
calm and cool because that wouldn't be
me
if i'm up there i'd be [ __ ] my pants
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
and they're just sitting like okay
anytime you want to go guys we're ready
yeah and you know how the cyclic is you
just touch those little controls and
that helicopter is going to crash and
burn
yeah like an airplane i was going to
mention when i said uh one of the when i
said you know first lieutenant so-and-so
was found this thing i i was
i should have mentioned hey by the way
what that means this guy is 23
yeah you know this guy is not an old
experienced pilot with thousands of
flight hours
he's 23 but like you said he might not
have
time but he's got ice in his blood
to sit there and hold station with a
freaking helicopter
while you're taking diska 12.7
millimeter rounds into the side of your
aircraft yeah and like
like with the lynn black story the
judging executioner
all year they came to our rescue time
and time again
and then with lynn they came in front of
the team and mowed down
a wave attack by the nva they couldn't
land took off and can't
continue to fight you know you you you
talk with such reverence for all the
other service branches and it's the same
you know when
when we were in the battle ramadi there
was just no rivalry whatsoever no
i've never had and i didn't really have
some big rivalry going into it i never
really cared i always thought we were on
the same team but some people
some people take that stuff pretty
seriously but man on the ground
in the battle of ramadi it was just
brothers
and and across the board and sisters as
well because there's females there
fighting and females that were killed in
action
and and but just nothing but reverence
for the soldiers the sailors the airmen
marines that we work with
salute to all of them and and certainly
i know you feel the same way
absolutely as you talk um but hey
once again thanks for coming back we got
to get the sog
cast going we will do it
uh maybe i'll take the post-graduate
record course on how to record
i'm telling you all right go echo might
be able to take it
um thanks for coming on and and more
important thanks for everything you did
to
protect our way of life here and and
thanks for what you continue to do
to support veterans here talking about
the mia's
what you've done with your veteran
organizations it's awesome
and um it's just an honor to know you
and it's honored to call you a brother
likewise brother thank you appreciate it
thanks man
like a bad dream we'll be back
and with that tilt
has left the building
unbelievable opportunity to sit here and
talk to these guys
and learn these stories so many stories
you know after we
after we turned off the mics i started
getting kind of crazy
talking to tilt i was saying hey when
you're talking about 600 hand grenades
getting thrown
yeah each one of those hand grenades
that gets thrown by the enemy
into your position is a whole story
there's a whole story behind it
yeah hey grenade all right where the
ground from i got him over there
start putting down fire i'm like that's
a whole story each one oh god
jimmy's wounded each one of these events
600 yeah grenades each one of those
events
is a is a micro story yeah
each one of these hey in in two lines
in this book that we just read in two
lines it's like um
hey there was enemy bunkers who were
cleared by the
mountain yards yeah wait wait a second
that's a freaking chapter or two
chapters or three chapters or a whole
book in itself clearing up
enemy bunker filled with the car or
with nva fighters
what's happening what are we talking
about so
to be able to sit here and talk to these
guys and and and tilt wasn't on that
particular mission but he has
you know he has first hand experience in
the ao
he lived through it and it's just
awesome
so appreciate the opportunity to do this
and and one of the reasons we have the
opportunity this is because you all give
us support
support sure as we like to call it
echo somebody wants to support this
podcast here
and while they're supporting this
podcast they actually want to provide
themselves
with some support yep is it close air
support
not really but it could be considered
on some level it is well let's just say
this it might not be close air support
but it is definitely support it is
support for sure
and for you know for oneself you know to
support others
you do have to support yourself right
like i
said i said it before i'll say it again
it's like you know when you're in the
airplane
and the oxygen mask comes down what do
they instruct you to do put on yourself
then you help your small infant child
whatever the case might be
so kind of same situation all right so
we're all working out we're keeping
ourselves
on the path on the path isn't just such
an esoteric thing by the way
it's keeping your [ __ ] together damn
i like it it is 100 in every way you can
by the way
mental physical uh social
social meaning like just your
relationships with people in and outside
your family anyway you understand you're
gonna know if you're doing something off
the path
versus something on the path you're
gonna know
pretty clear so anyway so when working
out
we could benefit from supplementation
we could use some air support some air
some level of
support yes there you go support is way
better than no support yes it is 100
so jocko has you covered we have you
covered we all have our cells covered as
well jackal fuel
supplementation for your joints
important
very important okay so i'm
i'm i'm not one of these guys who have
these crazy joint problems
but from time to time i'll get jammed up
you know the kind when you wake up
you walk downstairs if you walk
downstairs too quick you're like
you can feel it you see i'm saying you
don't know what i'm talking about
you don't feel that that's what you're
saying i certainly don't admit it
i thought we were all friends here you
know but i will say
and the point to this quasi story is
that
when you think back to those times when
you're like all stiff
or whatever just general stiffness and
now you don't have it it's like
it's it's a godsend is what it is
you don't miss those days we don't want
to feel it if you don't have to
yeah and it's it's not a big deal when
you forget it when you don't realize it
you see i'm saying but
anyway i realize it a lot so that's why
it is important to keep taking your
joint warfare
and krill oil those are for your joints
discipline
discipline go this is the brain
body supplement keep you mentally in the
game keep you sharp you have a groggy
day
boom helps you out that's what that is
um also rtd cans it's like an energy
drink
in the form of uh you know i got well
it's like an energy drink is something
that you drink that makes you feel good
for 45 minutes until you crash and burn
and you have a freaking insulin level
spike yeah and you feel like crap
yes because it's filled with sugar and a
bunch of chemicals
what's going on here no sugar
no sugar well how does it taste good
because it's sweetened with something
else called monk fruit which is actually
good for you
does it have 700 milligrams of caffeine
no it's got 95 milligrams of caffeine
yes good for you yep get that little
afternoon hater
yes so to sum it up i guess it's a brain
health drink in the form of an
energy drink
loosely we'll say it loosely we haven't
figured out what exactly we've made
it's a new category potentially yeah
okay it's good nonetheless got some good
flavors on there good uh some flavors
coming up
oh as well so excited about their
newfoundland
i'm not saying it's my new flavor i'm
not saying it's not my new flavor i'm
just saying
we have some various flavors coming up
anyway yes that's discipline and
discipline go there's also the
the capsules you know if you're in a in
a rush or what have you
yeah there's that also vitamin d3 and
cold war this is for immunity
so keeping your immune system is keeping
it
up keeping it strong that's important
definitely as opposed to unemployment
especially right now
yes well i i guess i don't want to get
into a whole debate
but i think that immune system is
important
at all times okay that's what i think
i'm going with it all right i'm very
curious
also what do we got milk jocko milk
protein in the form of dessert all
different kinds of desserts in the form
of protein
yeah you know what i'm saying yes i do
yeah yeah
same deal we've got some new flavors
coming out and i'll tell you what bro
i'll tell you what we got some flavors
coming out oh for real yes
oh okay yes and they are legit
okay legit you want to know what one of
them is
yeah smashing pumpkin
all right it's like uh i didn't even
know what this was yes
yeah i didn't even know what this was i
didn't know it was a thing yeah belittle
sends it to me he goes he goes dude you
gotta try this and i'm like
send it yeah it sends it out and i
wasn't even i didn't even know i liked
this flavor yeah smashing pumpkins yeah
but um well smashing pumpkins
is a band yeah yeah okay you already
knew that your fan you're smashing
absolutely yeah me too actually anyway
that's a ban pumpkin spice the flavor is
like a
thing like a yeah and i didn't know that
yeah and that makes sense because
i mean i knew of it but just in the past
like few years or whatever it's been
getting a lot of
like teasing and stuff like pumpkin
spice
i don't you know okay i don't know
anything about that i know yeah
i have to pull this flavor down because
it's weak no
i think like since it's been in the uh
what do you call like spotlight or
whatever
and people will be like oh i don't know
it's like they've been teasing it for
some reason
like you're some prep you can tease
pumpkin spice but trust me you're not
gonna tease smashing pumpkin
well here's the by the way you also said
smashing pumpkins that's plural that's a
band
that's not the name yes smashing pumpkin
we're going singular yeah yeah i dig it
because you know we won't want to
infringe
no no no you don't know you don't want
to infringe um
but no the pumpkin spice so that's the
thing where
it's almost like part of the reason or
part of the whole teasing
culture of it for lack of a better way
of putting it um
was that everyone likes pumpkin spice
but you know like
it's like if you're like tough you don't
want to like admit it like everybody
pumpkin spice is freaking delicious
in your cafe latte or whatever like
whatever it's always
everyone knows that you know that's like
kind of the thing that's why i'm going
to be honest i'm a little bit excited
for pumpkin spice
for smashing pumpkin we're not doing
pumpkin spice we're doing smashing
pumpkin because i'm starting to see the
connection here that you're making and i
don't think i like it
so we're doing something called smashing
pumpkin yeah and it tastes good
but it's filled with protein that will
make you strong
turn you into a destroyer
there you go yeah we got mold we got it
going out there yeah protein forming
dessert
also what do we got chocolate white tea
can you can you
are you into dead lifts doesn't even
matter because once you should be you sh
that's true too it's highly recommended
yeah to deadlift
and if you're going to deadlift you
might as well deadlift 8 000 pounds
and one of the quickest ways to do
everyone's looking for a hack i got a
hack for you you
don't want to worry about what your
periodization is going to be for your
dead lifting
well that's kind of a pain well what you
do is you drink chocolate white tea and
you're dead lifting
eight thousand pounds by the way
guaranteed yeah
and if you can't well
that's kind of on you really
and but i mean and that is good i kind
of painted myself into a corner
i had no way out you saved me i
appreciate it hey man well hey look if
you're not into deadlifting and i get it
i'm not gonna you can't judge
um well you can't a little bit you know
i overtly can't overtly judge about that
um it is certified organic and it's
very nice all right so you get all this
stuff at origen
maine.com you can also get it at the
vitamin shop
and pretty soon you're going to be able
to get the rtd
drink the jocko discipline go drink at
well you're going to be able to get it
at wawa in florida and virginia very
soon so be on the lookout for that we're
gonna have a little we're gonna have a
little operation go get some
yeah it's gonna be good also at origin
maine.com they got some
good jiu jitsu stuff american-made
jiu-jitsu where do you just throw the
word good out there like it's not
good yeah when actually it's the premier
jiu-jitsu stuff in the world
yeah yeah i guess it's like one of those
things little understatement
yeah don't worry i'm here i got your
back i got your six covered move
thank you anyway they got jeans as well
good
genes i say good as opposed to not good
okay like what are they not
as good as in the best things you can
put on your legs
ever yes in the history of america
pretty much
jeans boots t-shirts hoodies
what else i think we covered it anyways
a bunch of good stuff
and it's all made in america shorts
that's right shark fin
yeah they got some good stuff on how
about this go origin main.com
look at everything they got over there
all american made
and you might be thinking like well you
know that sounds good you know i
i could use some stuff for that stuff or
the other thing but you know i
you know i like to do things that are
beneficial to the world
you don't want to just consume right
right
well guess what go to origin main you
get some of that gear
you are contributing to the world you
are
bringing manufacturing back to america
we've got a bunch of
hard working american people
up there making it happen
and when you support
the cause you are doing good for
humanity that's true that might seem
like a big step
it is it's true yeah yeah
yeah and it's interesting we talked
about this before you
don't care that much about it how well
the fit
of the jeans are delta 68 and
the factory factory jeans yes anyway yes
or domain.com
also jocko has a store it's called jocko
store and this is where you can
get your apparel as it were if you want
to represent while you're on the path as
we
say so you know discipline equals
freedom t-shirts hats
do you know what bonafides are yes i do
you taught me yeah yeah so there's a
good bona fides
yeah you're just out in the wild and
maybe
you want to you know if you run into
someone else that's kind of on the path
maybe a trooper but you don't want to
walk around hey
hey how's it going hey are you in the
game it's like no no
no just put the flag on man you know put
the flag on put the deathcore flag on
yeah and someone and you you know what
you're not going to get bothered but
somebody will give you a look
your little head nod yep like what's up
yup maybe a little
maybe a little yeah what do you call a
little heart hitter
yeah yeah oh yeah but yes that's where
you can get it
jackal storytellerstore.com.com we got
some board shorts
on there summer we're wrapping up summer
are we wrapping up well i mean no we are
definitely wrapping up summer yeah but
you know i know some of us operate
more on a hawaiian type schedule so
summer
might be kind of past but some people
may still be wanting some board shorts
if
they're actually in hawaii well how
about this the board shorts
because that we currently have they're
multi-purpose
board shorts you can swim with them
surf with them do jiu jitsu in them or
just wear them
wherever they're going while you're
podcasting like i'm doing right now yeah
that's good that's your new uniform
right there but yes they did make they
do make the cut
yeah they're good but yeah a lot of good
stuff on there uh
yeah if you want if you like something
get some don't forget about that warrior
kids
soap from iris oaks ranch
you can get it on our on on
jacquasstore.com but it's a kid a
warrior kid with a company
who's making soap because his vision to
help humanity
is to help people of the world
stay clean also for the month of
september
irish oaks ranch is donating one dollar
per bar of soap
to cancer research sure so yeah this can
uh cancer awareness
month so boom that's what we're doing uh
subscribe to this podcast
check out some of the other podcasts
that we have jocko unraveling which used
to be called the thread but we changed
the name so jocko unraveling
soon to be on its own feed
we have grounded which we really haven't
recorded in a long time
we need to get that done and warrior kid
also not recorded in a long time
but you can listen to those podcasts you
can subscribe to those podcasts and this
one we also have a youtube channel
i i think the main value of the youtube
channel and this is me being kind of
serious
is for those of us who like to
watch the podcast two reasons one to
watch the podcast as it goes on like if
you have a
flat screen or you know one of these
smart tvs
in your office or your gym or whatever
you want to play it boom you want some
visual
uh what do you call it like association
you can see what john strucker
looks like sure yeah oh yeah there's
that for sure but you know when you have
it playing in the background it seems
like you're more in the conversation
anyway it's for that and also the
excerpts we have on there
so you know like you can get little
little as you and theophone would call
them
little or big
hitters were you trying to get me to say
hitters no i
i wanted you didn't you understand what
i'm saying anyway that in my opinion
that's advice so yeah subscribe to that
also psychological warfare is an album
with tracks jocko tracks
of jocko helping you get past your
moments of weakness
if they come if they come
let's face it they come they come oh
yeah for sure and yes this will help you
so yeah you can get on amazon or
wherever you
get mp3s from all good yep
flipsidecanvas.com my brother dakota
meyer's company
and yeah guess what guess what if you
want a little visual
representation to kind of keep you on
track
check out flipsidecanvas.com
and get something to hang on your wall
graphic
representation of the path
also got some books obviously these
books here by john striker meyer across
the fence on the ground sog chronicles
also don't forget about whiskey tango
foxtrot
by black jack lin black we got the code
the evaluation the protocols we got
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual we got way of warrior kid one two
and three we got mikey and the dragons
we got this one equals freedom field
manual
and by the way there's a new version of
that coming out
extended versions be advised a little
bit
some additional information
for your knowledge and also
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership also have a
consulting company called echelon front
where we teach
leadership principles and we solve
problems through leadership we also have
ef online ef online if you have a
question that you want to ask me
you sure you could send it into the into
the
interwebs facebook
twitter twitter the gram you could try
and ask me questions look
sometimes i get to them or you can come
onto efonline.com
and come to a live webinar where i am
sitting there in front of my computer
answering questions
go to efonline.com come and hang out
basically come and hang out
we have something called the muster
where you come
and physically hang out and learn about
leadership
we've had to cancel a few of them
because of the covid virus
but we we have one coming in dallas
texas december 3rd and 4th go to
extremeownership.com
if you want to come to that we have ef
overwatch
where we take people from the military
that have
the understanding of the principles that
we talk about
and we place those people into the
civilian sector into companies in the
leadership position go to
efoverwatch.com if you're a company that
needs
leaders we have america's
mightywarriors.org
mama lee mark lee's mom her mission
since she lost mark since we lost mark
has been to help service members around
the world
in all kinds of different aspects if you
want to get on board and you want to
help out
go to america's mightywarriors.org
and you can donate or you can get
involved and if you want to hear more
from us
you can contact us if you have questions
if you have answers
if you can fill in the blanks of some of
the blanks that we get to
you can find us on the interwebs for
tilt for john striker meyer he's on
twitter at sog
john instagram is at j striker meyer
and facebook is at john striker meyer on
the interwebs
he's got sogchronicles.com
and if you're looking for either one of
us two knuckleheads echo is that echo
charles and i am at jocko willink
and thanks to tilt of course for coming
back on to share the
stories of sog the sog chronicles
and more important thanks to tilt and
all his brothers in arms for their
service and their sacrifice
especially those who are still missing
in action
we will not forget
and we thank you and all of our military
for keeping
us free and to the police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and emts and dispatchers and
correctional officers and border patrol
secret service all other first
responders out there holding the line
thank you for your service and sacrifice
to keep us
safe here at home and to everyone else
out there
don't go around thinking
that you're hot [ __ ] and that your [ __ ]
doesn't stink
because you're bullshitting yourself
and if you do think that you are the
[ __ ]
then things will likely [ __ ] the bed and
then they'll go to [ __ ] and you'll end
up in a [ __ ] sandwich
and likely [ __ ] a brick when you realize
that you're up
shit's creek without a paddle
and that right there is some deep [ __ ]
so instead
focus on getting your [ __ ] together and
then keeping your
[ __ ] in line and look we all have a [ __ ]
ton of work to do
and not just chicken [ __ ] either but the
real [ __ ]
that can make us tougher than [ __ ] and
that is no
[ __ ] sherlock
so until next time this is echo and
jocko
out